hey guys big announcement trash taste is
officially going on tour
so we can't give too many details right
now but we do talk about it quite a bit
in this video so we just want to let you
guys know there will be more information
coming at a later date very soon anyway
guys on with the episode did you ever
have to look into your security no
because no one was like doing any
nefarious [ __ ] right yeah i say that but
somebody did mail a tub of [ __ ] to a
company a dress that i was registered at
i shouldn't laugh but that's very funny
it was in like a tupperware kind of
thing like here is your tub of horseshit
so how long did it take you guys to
realize it was horseshit it was probably
after my third spoonful
top of the morning to you ladies oh my
[Laughter]
apparently we weren't ready either
that's how i'm starting it off that's
i'm starting it off welcome to the trash
tape podcast i'm joey and i'm with
connor and gone as always and i had to
do that intro because of this guy
sitting next to me introduce yourself hi
i'm the token irishman for today yeah
awesome
have you ever had an irish person on
your podcast i don't believe we have no
no no i mean i don't know many irish
people to be yeah
yeah but uh yeah we got jacksepticeye on
yeah thank you very much for coming on
no problem yeah
pretty much yes
why how you doing
it's
how are you today
how are you good okay jeez yeah walk up
a little bloated but i'm feeling fine
now like what else like my stool was
good like
what do you want to know
yeah because you were telling us earlier
that you've only done like a few
podcasts in your entire youtube career
which considering how long you've been
on youtube absolutely likes is like
really surprising to me i mean no one
asks
everyone has their podcast is that the
secrets just ask yeah i think it's
because they're scared to ask you know
because when someone's like kind of like
well known and big it's like if i ask am
i like ins am i am i just you're just
too famous
i'm very intimidating whenever people
see me online like it's too
if you send the dm they don't reply back
you're just like you're destroyed for
the year yeah that's [ __ ] yeah but um
i guess i don't think there's anyone
watching this episode today who doesn't
probably
but just in case there is just in case
there's a person who's been under a rock
can you very briefly explain what you do
uh no in a non-cynical way if possible
um i
started off doing gaming videos on
youtube and it's since progressed into
mainly gaming but kind of everything
done right i have a coffee company i
have a clothing company none of which i
have with me which is very good
probably would have been the best time
yeah yeah i just haven't stickered all
over me yeah well we'll we'll get out
ready to put it on screen you know yeah
that's that's all good for joy's face
not why
yeah buy that
i'm like the same complexion as a coffee
bean so just put it on top i didn't say
that
but uh yeah and then you have amassed
how many [ __ ] subscribers now like
700 million whatever it is yeah yeah
yeah we'll go with that
it's a lot how about what do you want
right now that's like 28.4 i think yeah
just just a casual yeah i put down a lot
but yeah i wish like i gotta ask which
number did you just like stop like
looking at it and just stop caring about
it because i think like i think every
big youtuber i've talked to they reach a
point and then they just forget what
number that they're at yeah i think it
was after six million i think was when
because they were coming in so quick and
so often that it was like after six i
was like okay i don't know what to do
with this anymore right like a million
is like a big deal for everyone then he
hit five and then like between five and
ten is a little nebulous yeah yeah yeah
right i didn't know why people were
there and i was just trying not to annoy
anybody to kiss them all forget them to
go away so i was like just keep my head
down and stay going yeah yeah i'm not a
roster at that no no
no
not related yeah i can't relate it's
probably more of like a time exposure
more than it is like a milestone i think
right
i think subscriber milestones are kind
of easy to judge your time on youtube
yeah where they happen you kind of
remember them but i think for everybody
it's kind of like a time base after like
a couple of years you kind of yeah into
it you know who you are and what you're
doing and yeah that's right so so like
how long have you been on youtube like
like when was the exact beginning where
you started your first uploads
um end of 2012 so i'll be ten years at
the end of this year like very handy
for some reason i thought it was way
longer than 10 years
because you seem like it feels like
you've been around since basically like
the start of the platform at least like
from my perspective so hearing that it's
not even 10 years that like blows my
mind actually yeah it's really weird
because i'm i'm technically at like the
second generation because you have like
smosh and tobuscus
first gen right and then i for the
longest time i wasn't even considered
the second wave that people said that i
was like adding into the tail end of
that and then right
now a certain amount of time has gone by
and everyone's convinced i've been since
the beginning so yeah i don't know when
that happened
do people still use the whole generation
thing for even for like newer youtubers
now or is it just talking about more
yeah what generation are we in right
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm annoyed like
12th generation youtuber
i think people just know the cycles when
they come in but no one has a right
anymore
yeah i mean like because i remember it i
i think it was much easier to define
generations back then because uh one
people gave a [ __ ] about things like
youtube rewind so it was it was
it was much easier to like segregate
like oh okay i recognize these faces oh
and there's a new there's a lot of new
faces to youtube rewind and then
suddenly you're just like i do not know
anyone uh in this video it's also
because like you know during the first
couple of generations there was like a
literal handful of people that were like
the ones that made it right but now it's
like
how many people would you consider
the ones that made it yeah there's a lot
of channels now that have like 50 plus
million subscribers that you wouldn't
yeah i do like what happens i did like a
higher or lower thing where you like
guess youtube subs it's like a new
updated version of it with current stats
right and i went through and it was like
this person versus this person i was
like well they i think they're spanish
youtubers i was like they're gonna have
a lot obviously yeah i was like i have
no idea who this person is and it was
like 40 versus 50 million
i'd never heard of any of them yeah yeah
yeah it was crazy because the rewinds
went international then as well and
started involving like japanese people
yeah yeah yeah
i forgot about that yeah have them
wilder yeah i assuming you've been on
youtube rewind then yeah i think i've
been in two but i've never been there in
person right because every time they
asked me i either had something going on
or they asked me to do some [ __ ]
stupid [ __ ] where i was like
you get on a green screen and like
pretend you're falling through space
because that was the year like the katy
perry meme
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah not doing
that i was like
i was like i just won't be in it
because even if you are in it you're
probably in it for like one second yeah
almost right if i'm in it i want to be
in it for something like cool or good or
like yeah yeah yeah yeah or something i
was like i don't want to be like
everyone thinks i'm cringe already i
don't want to be in it for like
wacky on a [ __ ] green screen well
back then they did oh okay okay wait
what year was that like
i think it was like 2016 or 17 oh okay
like green hair era right oh okay okay
so it was like the peak of when i was
like a caricature of myself and then
everyone expected like a certain thing
well actually that's that's an
interesting question like would you say
at the beginning of your career you very
much were like a character caricature of
yourself
and that you've kind of like changed
your image as you've like evolved in
your career here on youtube i think in
the beginning i was like someone else
completely because i i started off and i
wasn't like being irish or like being
myself so i was like i'll speak clearly
and that was like hello everybody this
is me
for some reason it just sounded american
right right
yeah i mean i do the same thing whenever
i try and do american accent it just
sounds like markiplier yeah well you
have the toll right yeah yeah yeah
but i think i i was that for a while and
then i was like no one's watching no one
cares and i was like i'll just i lean
into myself and my culture a bit more
yeah like separate myself out and that
was where like top of the morning and
everything started yeah and then i think
after like four or five years then it
was like peak caricature because then
you're just you know what people like
you know what they want to hear
yeah like you guys will mention an anime
or something some point in this episode
i imagine yeah yeah you go through the
numbers yeah yeah you clearly haven't
watched them
episodes
you're gonna just know what your
audience wants yeah for a while right
right into that more and more so is that
like kind of what inspired the whole
like i guess screaming at the top of
your face yeah type of caricature right
like happy wheels like two a week and it
was like you know what people want they
love the catchphrase right
it's kind of like ticking boxes and then
you kind of get tired of that and yeah
something else well i feel like there
was like an entire generation of youtube
where like especially like the the first
wave of let's players it was very much
about a gimmick and
high energy it needed to be like high
energy right there if if you are
speaking below the decibels of like a
live concert then you you are just not
making it on youtube enough if your mic
was not peaking
yeah so people still like purposefully
peak their mic just to make it sound
louder right yeah yeah right they do
yeah i was like have you ever watched
like well because it's like a like a
deep-fried meme where yeah yeah yeah and
it's like the the
louder you shout like the cooler it
sounds i keep oh god every time i tune
in to like tommy and it's oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah tommy i love you you're great
you're super funny but fix your [ __ ]
microphone
i thought it was kind of like the tyler
one kind of mic yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah let's forgive him instead of him
being a [ __ ]
well we're not friends with
yeah
he just turned 18. he's not a child
anymore you should legally bully him
yeah
yeah
beat the [ __ ] out of you there
would be one felony
and you can go to jail now
my god so you're mentioning anime you're
a big anime guy
i want to be i want to write i want to
have like that knowledge of like the
obscure [ __ ] but i'm such a normie when
it comes to anime but most most
conversation you'll ever have about
anime is normally conversation that's
true yeah you can't know so many things
and you they never you just seem
pretentious if you're like i know this
show no no no no
you do you guys do seem pretentious okay
okay like absolutely we have all this
knowledge and then we have like the same
like conversations ninety percent of the
time anyway because everyone's watching
patients yeah that's that's what i've
learned recently though is that like it
doesn't matter how much actual knowledge
you have on the medium because 90 of the
questions are gonna be so what did you
think about the latest attack on titan
episodes yeah yeah yeah it's gonna get
to like that level right yeah that new
season of attack on titan sucks i hate
it i think it really i think we're
building up for the last one well yeah
yeah i'm being a bit harsh but i just i
feel like
carter we actually have it it was like
yeah yeah okay okay wait wait wait wait
we're getting into this now because i i
loved all the first three seasons i got
into the manga i read all of it
was like whatever it was i haven't read
it i haven't read them so you you're
even like ahead of us in this game then
yeah ending i was like yeah whatever and
then i was like waiting for it to happen
i was like there's a couple of good
scenes in there and then it happened i
was like papa are so much better than
that like
i feel like yeah jutsu kaizen came out
at like the same time and it's like
that's what you can do and this is what
we're getting right yeah you sound like
an anime fan yeah yeah yes this is
you're naming studios yeah yeah i like
the fact that you know what like the
base level of mapper is like more than
most people now i'm just pissing off
your audience
most of them don't come here for anime
but yeah yeah oh my god they can speak
about it yeah yeah yeah because like i
didn't expect that you would just name
drop an anime studio because that's like
even you call yourself a casual anime
fan but that level of knowledge is even
more than most people i talk to you know
what you like to do to kyson as well
yeah i [ __ ] love jiu-jitsu wow not
like him well
okay jiu-jitsu kaizen story is like
whatever it's all like by the book right
but i feel like it leans into that and
is like you're just here to watch cool
animation you're just here to watch cool
fights yeah it's like it's like this
show so much it's like naruto again but
it's like we cut out all the annoying
[ __ ] and just
it's like here's just fight scenes like
go for it yeah yeah also naruto doesn't
have like todo so like
that's true it's like the best character
but but it does have kakashi which is
just basically gojo just like all over
again yeah you know yeah but yeah
jojo's more marketable right jojo's
really easy
for the first time like last year yeah
yeah yeah i remember you yeah
oh how did that happen you watched
naruto the first time in 2021 well i did
too yeah because i remember you texting
me about it actually yeah like do you
think i should and i was like i mean you
go for it like yeah because my
girlfriend had watched it growing up and
that's right her into stuff and she's
she she lives in japan actually for a
long time oh really yeah
japanese and everything oh [ __ ]
okay she's she that was like that stuff
was what got her into it right right
right and then since i don't have any
nostalgia for i was like let's watch it
now and see if it holds up and we kind
of get a non-biased view on it yeah we
did like the non-filler sort of stuff
like yeah had listed on like reddit what
like the key was to watch websites
dedicated yeah yeah
there's there's nicely cut out like a
third of now yeah yeah yeah yeah i did
that and i was like it's still way too
long yeah yeah i was like we need a
naruto kai to come out
or a brotherhood
yeah because like i'm curious since
you've watched naruto last year i've
always thought that
it's like if you read the manga maybe it
would be a much better experience but i
think with the way anime production was
back then with a lot of filler not just
in episodes but within certain scenes it
would just just have dragged so much
do you think it's a good show
i think it is i think it has a lot of
heart to it and i think knowing the
pedigree that it has and the fact that
it started all of those trends that that
and dragon ball kind of like yeah
pioneered a lot of that like long
drawn-out battle kind of [ __ ] yeah and
the fact that that's why i'm saying like
jujitsu kaizen feels like that but
modernized yeah yeah yeah they cut out a
lot of the nonsense but at the same time
they cut out most of that jack has more
of an in-depth
opinion obviously i said compared to
like most people i agree though jesus
christ is just like we're getting on
with it [ __ ] yeah yeah he's like the
first episode like they just get right
into it whereas like yeah you can tell
shows from like 2000s when they take
their sweet [ __ ] time to let anything
happen oh like demon slayer yeah yeah do
you even say
naruto but the exact same where it's
like all the annoying characters all the
filler [ __ ] all of the like drawn out
battles all right all right the
animation's so good just do that over
and over again was there any animes you
watched that you were like i'll give it
a shot and you were like very surprised
that you enjoyed it uh full metal
alchemist
i love that shirt yeah same yeah
i i love full metal alchemist it's it's
it's amazing what's your favorite
character it's uh
the edge you know
everyone loves that [ __ ] he's right
that's all the truth that was one i had
heard a lot of yeah brotherhood
and then i watched it and i was like and
then it became my favorite of all time
oh because i was like it's just lean it
has a story to tell it gets in gets out
does it yeah i mean like i think like
for the anime community filmmaker
alchemist is kind of like the godfather
of like anime you know what i mean where
it's just like on the top of like every
top anime list of all time sacrilege
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it's just
always on the top but because everyone
looks there and they're just like yeah
you know i guess it's probably the top
you know i'm not going to argue that
full metal alchemist like i i haven't
even seen it and i'm just like yeah it's
probably the top you know
that was why i watched it because it was
on the top of everyone's list now yeah
sure i'll give it a shot and i was like
that makes sense yeah it feels really
unremarkable when you start watching it
but something about it just keeps you so
engaged and i don't know what quite it
is yeah actually it's just like a really
just put it on now we can watch it
my fans have been trying to get me to
watch for like five six years now but
like yeah as someone actually asking you
guys an anime question as someone who
hasn't seen formatted alchemists you
know you have you have shows like attack
on titan like jiu-jitsu guys like demon
slayer which you know is very much
critically acclaimed but there's always
like
there always seems to be like a group
that like is like anti like like like
tries to bring it down like the the
attack on titan is mid crew or the jiu
jitsu is mid crew or whatever but like
it just doesn't seem like that exists
for full metal alchemist
and i was just like why because i mean
for one it's like a genuinely good show
for one but i think it's also the fact
that now it's just put on such a
legendary status that it's like
i don't know there isn't i think it's
just a losing battle yeah if you go out
there and try to be that guy to be like
oh i think it's [ __ ] overrated or
whatever then everyone everyone i think
collectively is like okay sit down you
know
all right
it's just it's very lean like it has
like 65 episodes or something which
is like unheard of yeah it's just i
think because brotherhood came out it
did a lot of the heavy lifting because
the original one was kind of all over
the place yeah yeah yeah i had filler
stuff and everyone's like no one cares
just like here's like a decent story
starting to finish it keeps like having
twist and twist and twist and the pieces
right so
yeah i think it was just like yeah just
a well-oiled machine that just you know
was
good enough
it was lubed the [ __ ] up it was really
smooth it worked perfectly like
everything it tried to do it did well
yeah those are pretty mature for
that era i think yeah there's still a
lot of like [ __ ] up scenes like even
in today's standards i think i think
even like in the mainstream i think
attacking titan's the only thing yeah
since that's like like people are
[ __ ] dying left right and center yeah
yeah i mean i think like attack on titan
is because most time when an anime gets
super super popular it's basically just
shonen jump it's you know shows like
juicy guys and demon slayer might hear
academia then attack on titan has been
like
the adult show i guess the most adult
show that's gotten as close to
mainstream as i think anime has gotten
even though it's still technically a
shown in mario yeah even yeah it is
technically
you know even though it technically is
published and shown in magazine you know
it's it's seen as like more mature
especially you know you watch attack on
titan and you're like this ain't no my
hero academia you know
definitely not do you have like a
favorite anime or manga then
uh favorite anime is full metal um it
used to be well it was like the first
season of one punch man i really loved
ah okay okay okay second classic like
a step down and i was like ah man you
could have just left it there it wasn't
fine
i think i think i know what your
favorite monger is
it's it's berserk right yeah yeah you
read berserk i feel like anyone who's
read berserk oh my god it's like top of
their list yeah yeah yeah i think it's
my favorite too because i i started and
again like full metal it was like top of
everyone's list now yeah like dark souls
like from soft or huge into them i was
like i'll give it a shot and then i had
the dark horse like
oh the thick ones the thick ones right
yeah one of those for a long time i was
like pandemics happening i'll finally
read it and then right just blasted
through the whole thing right yeah yeah
it's uh same i did it it's just pandemic
as well i'm [ __ ] man i don't know it's
just really comfortable yeah anyone
who's like hasn't read it and hears us
talk like that it's like it's it's worth
it it's a lot of it's really drawn out
but it's like the only thing that
actually benefits from it i think yeah
absolutely yeah
yeah i i feel like the pacing is perfect
for the story it wants to tell it
doesn't it's not always like an action
fest but i feel like even like the
quieter moments just draw you in and
immerse you so much i think for me the
quieter moments of berserk is what i
enjoyed the most they hit really hard
yeah yeah
there are some panels that are just like
so still and yet it's like i don't know
very intense at the same time it's very
difficult to explain but i just like the
scale of it because it sets up it's like
okay here's one bad guy and then he
follows that the entire way through
they're not like here's an ark with that
bad guy and then yeah someone else and
then yeah like reeling through it being
like okay when do we get back to good
[ __ ] again yeah it's like one one pillar
the entire way through and then the hero
is like
it doesn't do that stuff like his power
level goes down and then it goes back up
and down it's like it's just very
consistent the whole way through and
it's more about the interpersonal drama
yeah than anything i knew it was special
because you know when you get like one
third of the way through something and
you're like oh no yeah oh no i'm getting
through this yeah it's gonna end i'm
gonna have to say when you go to the
golden age and it's like wait this isn't
a flashback
and you're like that's the prologue
that's the prologue to the story
but yeah a shame with that we're never
gonna see the end of it i still haven't
like i've still not brought up the
courage to read the final like few
chapters yeah i still haven't read the
final volume it's just yeah i'm like
sitting all night it's a bigger weeb
than you guys did i've done it i read it
i bought it i bought it on release i got
like the special like uh like soundtrack
edition to it as well and but i'm just i
don't want to read it because i know
once i read that that's it there's no
more bizarre there's no
i totally agree have they said like
definitively if it's like done now or
not so
for a little while there was this rumor
that was going around where hack sancho
the the publishers were thinking about
continuing on the series and then it got
a ton of backlash online yeah just being
like nah dude just just let it go to
rest so right now we don't know yet
there is a possibility that they might
i personally don't want that because
yeah yeah because again like i haven't
read the last couple of chapters but i
heard that like the last couple of
chapters actually kind of has like a
somewhat round ending to it right or
yeah it feels like you're getting very
close to the end yeah yeah just in a
weird way you can kind of predict what
you think yeah yeah yeah yeah this year
and i i i don't feel like you know
obviously miura is like one of the
arguably the greatest mangaka who's ever
lived you know especially with his
masterpiece berserk and just who would
even one who would even want to try to
even take up that mantle you know like i
wouldn't want to be that person you know
um and like you know two it kind of just
feels
to me at least it kind of feels
disrespectful if you know someone passes
away and you know there are some
instances that maybe you know some
people can continue on their vision if
they know what's going to happen but in
this case it just feels like such a
personal story that i don't really feel
like anyone can tell it but miura
himself yeah yeah maybe we'll get like a
thing of like his notes or like yeah
yeah book of what he was thinking would
happen i feel like that's the best way
because then people can just make your
own endings yeah fill in the blanks
right i'd never be disappointed by an
ending that doesn't happen yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
i saw something similar to that when i
went to the berserk exhibit though it
was like a cut that was trying to rub it
in now yeah
he's like let me let me flex on you
right now
real quick yeah there was like a there
was like kind of a glass cabinet of like
a bunch of like mirrors notes that were
kind of written down and there was like
not nothing really like concrete that
went after the manga yeah after where
the manga ended but um it was just
really cool to see like i guess it's
like thought process and like sketches
on like a bunch of [ __ ] because like
it's like really just super fine stuff
like very very basic shapes for
characters who then ended up being you
know characters like zod or like yeah
you know these like insane
pieces of art essentially in longer form
yeah um but yeah what was i going on
about yeah i went to the berserk
professional podcast
that wasn't even like a question that
was just his
yeah so did you have a point joey or did
you just want to rub it into us yeah
that's all
[Laughter]
have you ever been to japan yourself uh
once yeah we
uh
oh god what year was it it was before it
was like 2019 i think right um right
before the pandemic yeah we went because
i got offered to go to a thing with
because godzilla was coming out and
detective pikachu oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah second godzilla movie so we
got to go with like warner brothers flew
us out to do a thing right and then
because my girlfriend lived there and
she's fluent and everything was like can
we like extend our trip so we went for
ten days oh nice nice four on our own
and then the rest was like doing stuff
with that
awesome yeah did it feel like it was
enough days were you like oh no i need
more i think for that trip it was
because we ended with all the like
pressed junkies yeah okay okay
it felt like we we like revisited the
same place we went to like harajuku the
first time when we were there and then
like the temples and stuff and then when
we went back it was like here you go
again but it's like
scheduled out so it was a little
different but yeah we got to go to the
the touhou place and we got to see like
all the original like props for all the
earlier movies
right right like the original like
costume and everything was there yeah
yeah yeah yeah that stuff was really
cool got to see ryan reynolds again
oh yeah yeah yeah
he waved at me you're in free guy yeah
well that was the thing i met him for
the deadpool thing and then the
detective pikachu thing he was on a boat
he was like hey that guy and he like
waved down at me
i was like holy [ __ ]
he remembered he remembered me
and then we like took a picture all
together and i was like standing next to
him being like
cool good to see him i will remember
this smell so there's a lot of things in
that trip that like made it a much
bigger deal yeah yeah yeah well how did
like the free guy and like the deadpool
collab come about and what was it like
you know being in projects like that
fluke right
when
the deadpool deadpool was coming out the
second one
and then i'd love the first one already
and i was such a massive fan of ryan
anyway yeah and then i was talking about
him so much in my videos and just kind
of like kind of annoyingly i would say i
feel like if if someone did that
i'd be like [ __ ] weirdo
but i i've been talking about him so
much that he liked one of my tweets one
day because
people were just badgering him about me
yeah yeah i was i was coming back from a
trip one time and then saw on my phone
that he had followed me and i was like
oh [ __ ]
i was like it was like dad found my
account oh no
delete everything yeah but then i think
that happened and then i had played the
deadpool game
just because for search engine the movie
was coming out yeah yeah yeah yeah
played people were watching and then
i think warner brothers whoever were
over at the time got wind of that and
then got in contact with me and we're
like well now we have to put you in a
room together because you guys have
interacted you've played the game and
yeah
then because of that it like snowballed
from there to like all the other
celebrities right
wow it was just random chance it was a
pure miracle that's so cool though
basically just meme up your favorite
celebrity right and then just yeah yeah
he has to be the biggest fan boy yeah
that's like the worst story ever just
keep tweeting at them just make as much
noise as possible your favorite
celebrity and then eventually they'll
notice you annoy the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
um yeah that's so cool though you were
also in uh was it poppy play time the
newest one recently that was that was i
i played the game and i was like is that
because it's not like the grainiest
[ __ ] i'm like is that yeah and you
just see like my chin
and then once my full face comes in
everyone has the same reaction yeah yeah
yeah what was that all about i mean
like again in the first chapter i was
like yeah i could do a voice in this
game put me in the game and then they
messaged me afterwards being like do you
want to be in the game i was like it's
that easy yeah i just [ __ ] annoy
people
but i i've been in a couple of things
like bendy and the ink machine and papa
combo did oh okay yeah so i think they
were just like yeah be in it but i i
didn't think i'd be a person in it they
were like
it was just tapes of voices the first
time and i was like i can i can do that
oh you thought it was just going to be a
voice of you yeah yeah right and then
they sent me the thing and it was like
dress up in like a yellow shirt and like
have a lanyard which they didn't give me
a template for and i had to make right
um and then i was like okay i'll act and
i was like [ __ ] now i have to like learn
the lines like be in a camera and like
right
took me like seven times just to get
like a sentence over this feels like a
big brain though instead of having to
play the game yourself just be in every
other lesson yeah yeah
it works out great then i played and i'm
like i'm in puppy play time you have a
thumbnail of you
yeah how is it like having to like
memorize a script versus just you know
doing a let's play or just being a
youtuber i guess because i feel like
there must be so much more pressure
because yeah yeah do you have like an
acting background
yeah well you're just waiting not at all
yeah just winging it i just well i i'm a
huge fan of just watching movies and i
love acting in general and i always
thought i would do it eventually yeah
and i have like mini characters on my
own channel where i like play them every
now and then and yeah yeah want to do
something with those in the future and i
that was like a sandbox for me to just
play around in it though and be like if
i can do it i'll figure it out
but these things was like just here's a
roll if you want to do it right right
right for them here and there and
i don't know it's weird
it's a fun challenge though i think yeah
oh definitely definitely yeah because i
guess uh i guess i guess you just kind
of like in three guys it was kind of
like a cameo so you kind of just got
like to play yourself i guess right yeah
it was really bizarre because when i
when they sent me the thing being like
if you want to be in free guy and i was
like it's a movie with ryan reynolds why
wouldn't i be i was like i'll do
literally anything
my boy ryan my boy
you open up your ryan reynolds shrine
and you're just like you flex berserk on
me i'll flex right now
that's definitely a bigger flank yeah he
texts me a video for my birthday this
year oh oh no saying like happy birthday
and like damn
that's like a 700 cameo right there
just got your name wrong
good to see you john
but yeah for free guy it was i got like
a script of like there's like a bunny
rabbit character in it when they go into
the world right and it was like those
lines and i was like oh [ __ ] that's like
a character and i thought it was like oh
just walk in the background yeah yeah
yeah yeah sean levy the director i had a
call with and i was like here learning
these lines and i was like okay treat
this as an audition okay and i was like
[ __ ] and breaks i'm even getting nervous
now thinking about it right it was so
scary and then i got on the phone with
him he's the most infectiously happy guy
of all time he was like yeah we have
this movie and we're gonna do it we'd
love to have you in it and it's so cool
like you'd play yourself and i was like
oh this is i don't have to do anything
did i get the pot
should i do a british accent
so did i get the audition how do i how
do i how do i stack up against the other
jacksepticeye auditions
honestly i would lose that order
i have no idea how to be myself
but he like he'd like text me the lines
like a script right for an sms and i was
like oh we're just shooting from the hip
wow and i got to sit in my room like
with my camera and do it as like they
were like have it to us by like monday
or whatever but i was allowed to do it
on my own with no direction and right
they came back and they were like that
was incredible we want you to in it more
here's more lines so
if you watch the movie it was like the
very starting part was the only part i
had initially right i kept showing up
again and again because they were like
you were so good let's put you in again
and i was like great and then they were
like yeah ninja was like in it and he
sent us like a c920 logitech webcam
i was like ninja come on
so then his part in the movie has like
like a motion rig and like a really big
camera yeah now mine looks like [ __ ]
super fun really really cool experience
to be part of you know people like as of
like two days ago my chiropractor
messaged me being like i saw free guy it
was incredible i didn't know you were in
it
yeah that is an awesome flex this
episode of trash chase is sponsored by
pc specialist
pc specialists are one of the leading
custom pc manufacturers in europe
specializing in gaming pcs laptops
workstations and more they have a focus
on building high performance systems for
gamers gamers enthusiasts sim
enthusiasts that's me content creators
fashion users that's us and
professionals that's nice
their easy to use configurator allows
you to customize each component of your
build to your desire and each pc is
meticulously cable managed to ensure
neatness and tested to ensure stability
and performance unlike the voice pc's
how dare you all of their pcs are
powered by windows 11 playtime anytime
so if you want a new gamer pc then click
the link in the description and use code
trash at the checkout
back to the episode i guess you talked
about before how you felt like you
played like a caricature you know
at which point did you start to like
kind of like not get maybe like not get
tired of it but maybe think like you
should just try to be with yourself more
was there like an exact moment or
realization yeah i think it was like i
think it was a couple of moments i think
at the end of 2017 i have like a video
on my channel saying it was like the
worst year of my life and i was just
miserable i was in like a really crappy
place mentally yeah it was like the
first time i ever got to like the end of
the year and i spent christmas alone and
i was like my mind went to some very
dark places which i won't get into
detail of right but i was like that's
that's not me i don't normally think
like this like clearly something's wrong
and i start like going to therapy and i
start trying to figure myself out and my
priorities and then i think like the
next two years after that we're still
trying to like figure [ __ ] out yeah i
don't know what i want to do do i do
daily uploads again do i work on bigger
things and then kind of getting sick of
myself and yeah i kept taking breaks
so periodically and going away for like
a month or two months yeah trying to
figure stuff out and then
i think last year after my dad had
passed i was like okay
i'm quitting i'm doing i'm [ __ ] out i
hate this yeah i hate where the culture
of youtube is going i hate everything
that's going on i don't want to play
into the games of it yeah and i was like
i just took some time away and i was
like well i don't have to take it that
seriously i started off doing it like
kind of in my bedroom having fun yeah
just uploading daily games and like
subscribers don't really matter that
much if you're having fun with it and
things are sustainable and views don't
matter that much as long as you're still
making like your living out of it yeah
been so successful with it so far that
i'll just have fun with it again and i
think yeah all of those pieces kind of
culminated and i was like that's it's
fun to do
yeah i mean i i think
since we've all done youtube for like
quite a long time we forget sometimes
that youtube is a fun job you know
because
there's a lot of times when the grind
can feel endless and you can forget
sometimes that you started it because
it's fun and it is a genuinely fun job
and i feel bad like saying this because
i'm sure a lot of people would like
obviously like kill to be in
in this position but a lot of times when
you hear youtube's talk about that job
it's always in like a negative
connotation uh yeah because it's well it
becomes a thing that when you do it to a
certain level and you get sustainable
and you start earning money often you
get
you get to a point where like your
financial side of things are kind of in
check and yeah yeah yeah you can you can
afford rent and food which is most
people struggle in the friction in their
life and then
we we make our own hours all you're left
with are like emotional problems that
you kind of have to deal with right
figure those out and then you have to
figure out your own brain and then
i think for a lot of people it's easy to
blame youtube for like things going
wrong in your life if
algorithms shift and yeah kind of
like go wrong yeah or if an upload does
bad it's like ah [ __ ] the system and
it's like
maybe the video wasn't that good yeah
yeah yeah yeah
people are very quick to blame the the
algorithm yeah there is a factor too of
course it's not all perfect yeah but i
think you know putting all your problems
on the algorithm is something else yeah
right it's like an easy out sometimes
yeah i mean i've done it too i still
kind of do i think we all have that i
think that's like a path that every
youtuber does definitely go through at
one point in their careers it's just a
matter of like whether you can realize
that that is not the entire truth you
know yeah because you put your entire
self-worth into that and when it's
successful it's like i'm amazing i'm
doing great yeah yeah if that dips then
it's like i'm a piece of [ __ ]
i don't know
how this works anymore that person
uploaded and it's fine and i do the same
thing yeah yeah and then like and
someone new comes on and gets like
[ __ ] 50 million views doing like some
something that you just think is so
simple or something you're like wow why
is the algorithm favoring this video and
you just like feel like a lost soul
sometimes can't imagine the daily
uploads uh make it uh easy to
have
time to think about yourself and where
you are right now
i've never done daily uploads but that
sounds terrifying i think it sucks i
barely already have enough time to
consider my own mental health i feel
like adding in the daily uploads like
where do you
how was that like yeah because how long
did you do daily uploads for that's like
five and a half years oh my it was it
was double daily did you just have like
no social life during that point oh okay
i was editing everything myself i would
wake up get a video ready for that day
or the two videos ready for that day
then record two more edit them that
night and then go to bed
oh my gosh
i don't do that
it's great when everything's like firing
and like you're getting into it there is
a passion there like sure work hard when
it's there and everything yeah booming
but take some time for yourself yeah so
did you take any breaks at all
seriously i think it was like
seven years before i took my first
proper like time off oh my god that was
circumstantial for being on tour because
i was like i can't upload yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i tried vlogging on tour and
then i wasn't doing my tour properly and
yeah it was just too much but that was
like the first time i was like oh people
will still be there if i come back yeah
yeah because i feel like there is
definitely when you set yourself a
schedule and that's how you get like a
lot of success and a lot of traffic
initially you think that you need to
stick to this upload schedule this like
uh expectations that you've set for the
viewership and i think like one thing i
will say is i think youtube's a lot
become a lot more lenient at least
recently
uh with just like realizing that your
audience is what really holds the power
and even if you go to like a second
channel they will like your audience
will follow you yeah yeah i definitely
think like nowadays like you know when
like when you were starting off
especially i think the general consensus
was like if you're not uploading daily
then you're not even in the game you
know whereas like now i think the the
the knowledge of that not necessarily
being true and that as god was saying
like your audience will be there even if
you you know change stuff around or you
move stuff around i think now it's just
become more like commonplace i think
where it's like you know now you have
channels that are starting off who
aren't as pressured to do daily uploads
if they don't want it right like there
are lots of successful channels now that
probably upload like once a month yeah
as long as the video is good i just
think the general level expected of the
videos has just gotten crazy oh yeah
yeah but that's the thing with daily as
well it's like the daily videos weren't
good yeah yeah yeah yeah it was just
like chopping out bits and then that's
it yeah like heavy editing on them no
because you can't do it like it's
physically impossible to find the time
to do that right unless you're planning
you know weeks ahead but and they were
so much shorter as well like these days
20 minutes right yeah even i even it was
like 10 15 minutes something right it's
a lot more manageable yeah like eight
minutes was like the golden zone back in
the day right it was so weird playing a
game for like 10 minutes then be like
all right guys
calling it a day yeah i mean that was
like early felix was like amnesia was
like 10 minute episodes yeah yeah yeah
yeah you're trying tomorrow for the next
part yeah that would take you like a
whole month just to get through like a
chunk of the game because i remember
early game grumps was like that as well
was like it was like 10 minutes an
episode it's like all right see you
tomorrow yeah that was normal but now
it's like unthinkable everyone wants
like three hour videos now yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah well it's all it's all
like idea first yeah content after for
most of like the most successful
platform like in that time did you have
like a basic
work schedule did you were you just like
okay i'm going to play this game for
this long block out this time to play
game and block out this amount of time
to like edit this
kind of segment or was it just whatever
i i don't think i was conscious of it
but i think it just happened naturally
within my day i didn't even go to my own
college graduation because i was like i
need to edit this video
so i just got my degree mailed to me and
that was oh and everyone else went out
for like a graduation party and i was
like i guess i'll go out for a couple of
drinks
i have to be home to work though like
nobody else understood it right right
now now it seems kind of silly to do
that yeah yeah enjoy yourself and have
fun but back then there was no like you
can't put your foot in the break at all
yeah yeah yeah there's no work like
ethos yeah he's getting lost in the
shuffle then yeah because i was doing my
first two and a half years of youtube i
was doing daily uploads as well
while i was a full-time uni student and
the only reason why i stopped doing
daily uploads is because my computer
literally exploded on me
like if my computer never exploded and
like basically just completely stopped
the ability to even like make videos
then i'd probably still be doing it for
as long as maybe you did it yeah even
then it's like i can't imagine you never
missed a day for five years was there
some days you missed i think so i think
there was one day i missed because holy
[ __ ] a tree fell down from a storm and
cut out our power it literally took like
an act of god yes
my internet was so [ __ ] at home as well
that i would take them to college and
upload them oh my god
i i presume you know during the whole
five years right there was like i don't
know two three years in you were pre
doing pretty well for yourself oh yeah
yeah so what made you continue when you
had already gotten to a point that was
really successful that you felt that i
need to keep doing this
well part of it was the emotional side
of things where you kind of don't want
to be by yourself yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
all you know is the noise and if you're
constantly busy then nothing can creep
up on you yeah yeah yeah
and then
you know i think the landscape had kind
of like started to shift and the demand
for i think it was like like life of
strange one came out and felix did like
a whole
like the whole chapter in one video yeah
that was unheard of at the time i was
like you [ __ ] idiot you gave away all
these views
that could've been like four episodes
and then it paid off so well for him and
i was like oh wait watch time is such a
big factor that everyone just started
doing it yeah yeah yeah you just
couldn't do daily really anymore if you
were doing that right right so you
didn't like you did you missed
christmases new years everything never
oh my god because i was always like well
well i didn't like work on christmas
right right you'd
some people are alone at christmas i
want videos for them to go out yeah yeah
yeah i was like i don't want to
disappoint anybody right yeah yeah like
they could they come every day like
after school or after college or
whatever yeah and i guess that pressure
just kept going as the subscriber count
got higher yeah yeah yeah yeah jesus and
then we went to like a a youtube
summit in new york in like 2016 and like
me mark felix like a whole bunch of
casey neistat and a whole bunch of other
people were there
and then my youtube rep kept like like
showing me around being like this is
sean he is like one of the fastest
growing channels on the whole platform
this year right i was like what
like you didn't [ __ ] tell me that
and then i like went up and like susan
wojcicki was there and like my contact
was like this is sean he runs like
jacksepticeye and she was like
uh-huh and i was like okay so what
you're saying doesn't mean [ __ ] right
i was like gassing me up to all these
people and you talked to the ceo of
youtube and had no idea who i was she
did an interview with uh ludwig that was
looked pretty good yeah yeah yeah she
seemed very chill about it i don't know
if that should be i guess she wasn't in
tune with the youtube sphere batman yeah
had like just started to get bigger yeah
yeah yeah since then she's been very
very nice to me and she's had a lot of
good things to say yeah she's i want to
forget
i want an applause i want a second play
button
they say first impressions don't really
matter obviously susan you know it does
okay
she she just got blindsided by me yeah
she's lovely everybody yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
susan for like the ceo of youtube it's
like you think she knows what's going on
the ad department don't even talk to the
marketing department at youtube like no
one [ __ ] knows what's going on
too fast i imagine it when you're at an
event with like every other big youtuber
it's unremarkable if another youtuber
comes right right yeah this is another
one yeah it's like you're there at a
summit with like all like some of the
biggest yeah yeah yeah what's another
one to you
one thing i've always wondered is so
we've talked quite a bit on the podcast
about how you know the reach we have has
definitely like affected our lives uh
like off of youtube and especially at
conventions and stuff like that like us
three put together is like a fraction of
the reach that you have like how has it
affected your life like i'm sorry
i'm genuinely curious about what like
your lifestyle is like and how you've
had to adapt because
it was a little weird in the beginning
because like when you meet fans for the
first time in real life it's kind of
scary and it's like oh and i lived in
like a small town and i was like oh
they're going to find out where i live
they eventually did right right people
show up at my door like three times a
week
seriously
yeah there was like there was one time
that i always remember because i lived
in like a gated apartment area right and
they got in at like 9 a.m i was like how
the [ __ ] did that happen turns out my
neighbors let them in
because they said boys and they were
like he loves meeting people
i don't know you and it was like it was
like a polish family like a mother and
her two kids and they had this big
wooden board with like youtube written
on it and my name oh i wanted to give
this to you and i was like standing
there in like my underwear shirt
having just rolled out of bed
on the american accent and just been
like no no this is markiplier
i don't speak english
you should have hit them with the korean
it got really scary at that point and
then we we moved to brighton and then i
was like militant about not having my
address anywhere and yeah trying so hard
to like keep things secret and i think
that that kind of messed me up for a
long time like even when i would stream
i was so paranoid that i would like show
amazon or something and i would have
like post coding yeah yeah yeah i've
been very terrified of that too yeah or
anything would just show up on my
desktop that like gave a hint to where i
am or what i was doing or like even like
the time on my clock so i got really
paranoid right right right um but that
was also like fan fervor and they were
all like really big into like shipping
and really like oh fanatical about
everything yeah that era of yuju
which is swinging back now with all the
minecrafters yeah i mean it still it's
it's coming back yeah yeah yeah it's
definitely coming back thankfully my
audience have just kind of like matured
with me and kind of settle down and yeah
i think i think the main thing that i
got out of it was that i didn't set
boundaries early enough right right and
i think a lot of people are scared of
setting those boundaries because it's
like it makes their audi they think
their audience are going to hate them
for doing that yeah yeah like oh you
don't want us as close you keep saying
you love us and yeah you actually hate
us and you don't want us to come to your
house yeah
[Laughter]
no i don't i skipped about seven steps
there yeah it was like trying not to
rock the boat at all trying to piss
people off yeah because i remember like
i guess we like
people like us have to be thankful to
like the experiences that you went
through because back then it did very
much feel like the boundary just didn't
exist and if youtubers talked about it
then the consensus was well why are you
complaining about this this is this is
they made you they made you why why
aren't you grateful that fans love you
so much you know
i remember that during the whole like
team 10 house remember that oh like so
many videos because we could put the
address in [ __ ] public yeah yeah yeah
yeah there's like a listed google place
yep yeah and then it would turn up and
they'd be like no [ __ ] off and then
there's just so many videos of parents
being like we made you do you know you
wouldn't be this without us
they bought all your shirts
you literally wouldn't be in this
location without me yeah exactly exactly
i mean thankfully it does seem like the
you know the mentality because of so
many bad uh interactions and bad fan
stories that you know people are kind of
getting the point now so you know
thankfully so yeah yeah did you ever
have to look into security or anything
like that did they ever get to that
point no because everyone was just so
nice about it no one was like doing any
nefarious [ __ ] right right it was like
he didn't have the super weirdos coming
up yeah i say that but somebody did mail
a tub of [ __ ]
to
like a company address that i was
registered at what um
apparently there's a website that you
can mail
like
different types of [ __ ] to people
so what it showed up
that's very funny but it showed up at my
house was horse [ __ ] but you could get
pig [ __ ] cow [ __ ] dog [ __ ]
and that was like when i was like oh you
guys are [ __ ] weird was it was it
labelled as horseshit i think so yeah
it was like a tupperware kind of thing
like here is your tub of horseshit sir
yeah but it didn't come directly to my
house i went to like a business address
that i was yeah right right how long
hair like was like should we throw this
away and i was like yes so how long did
it take you guys to realize it was
horseshit there was it was sitting there
and just like something smells time for
the taste test
it was probably after my third spoonful
that's horseshit
rather bizarre phone call to receive
jack we had
a box of [ __ ] did you order this because
somebody sent a cake to me before right
and i was like okay i'm not eating that
yeah of course
actually i did eat it that was stupid
i was like i've done that as well that
was like 2015. we didn't know
that's how we left the taste of [ __ ]
it was mixed into the cake yeah it
wasn't a chocolate cake
that was the same story just you know
yeah
that was at the point like those were
almost like back to back where i was
like yeah right i was kind of weird that
you're sending stuff to me instead of
like showing up at the house yeah
yeah i think i've seen enough of like
those kinds of videos and like heard
enough of those kinds of stories to know
like because you know during that time
when you're starting off right like
people are like oh so like when are you
going to get a p.o box yeah like send
stuff and hearing stories like that from
early on i was like yeah
never never
no no i yeah i had one it got really
crazy i just imagine it got overrun so
fast yeah you kind of just think like
where am i gonna put all this yeah yeah
and uh yeah well that happened at
conventions i would go to conventions
and people just send us like boxes of
stuff or bring them up to the meet and
greets right it's like i i like paid
like hundreds of dollars to ship it back
to my house yeah yeah yeah it was like
these are so many items it was like
three three or four boxes worth of stuff
yeah yeah yeah you want to do with all
of this and then you run out of space
then you have to move and it's like i
feel awful having to like do stuff with
this and it's like
you don't want to like tell people that
you have to like throw some stuff away
which is like awful to think about yeah
i like literally cried one time i was
like having to like put stuff in a bin
and i was like i let everyone down
oh man
and then now i'm like
but that was the thing like no boundary
and now yeah no gifts at these things
anymore because i can't do anything with
you yeah yeah because it's like it's
more of a logistical thing now where you
go you literally can't can't take
everything home and a lot of it
especially like food stuff is it's now
like a health and safety concern maybe
it's got horseshit in it like who
[ __ ] knows anybody
you never know someone gives you a
colvin cake
oh no
that's something that's something i
didn't think we needed to worry about
until now
i don't yeah someone out there that's a
fantastic idea people who just met you
guys at the comic-con were like [ __ ]
missed out guys that necklace i gave him
could have been a cold video yeah
exactly
just gotta check if anyone's coughing on
that gift before
[Laughter]
people like put in the hand sanitizer on
the apples and stuff oh yeah oh yeah
what are you doing
fighting covert that's it yeah just
a bizarre way yeah not getting covered
but eating hand sanitizer at the same
time yeah have you had like aside from
getting horseshit sent to you have he
had any weird fan interactions just like
at conventions or at events or anything
like that oh yeah because he used to go
to quite a few conventions yeah i think
i think i'm done with them now i think
in 2020 was like right at the start of
the pandemic like right a week after
that was when lockdown happened right
and i got violently ill so i'm
i think i got covered like right at the
beginning
was testing that yeah yeah yeah some
people had like pulled out of vidcon for
that
um and after that i was like i risked
dying for a convention and i was like
maybe it's not worth it right and then
i'm like when people go there they don't
really get an interaction with you
anymore because it's like if someone's
there with a timer for like 30 seconds
and it's like a picture shake thank you
goodbye
it's like i don't want to meet people
that way yeah yeah yeah exactly um
what's what like what's the vidcon
experience like because yeah i'm not
enough to say like i've only heard the
most like [ __ ] wild things from
people like yeah whether whether it be
positive or negative here wasn't so bad
because i think people here have a
different culture and a different sort
of mindset like europeans are a bit
camera than americans would be
i'm not i'm not stereotyping you [ __ ]
air
i've done a tour in the whole world i
know what you people act like
um
but in in vidcon in l.a was [ __ ]
batshit crazy it was like the walking
dead and is it just scary yeah yeah it
was terrifying we weren't allowed out
onto the main hall because you just
weren't they have like a couple of hours
scheduled after one of the days where
creators can go out and experience it
right now wow there's no wow
yeah it's like there's like a snapchat
booth and like i did see it looked very
uh anemic yeah it's working it's very
corporate it's very like branded and
it's very kind of boring for anyone
who's there so people are just there to
see creatives yeah and then like as that
was happening we got to walk down the
main hall and all these fans like
hundreds of them at the window like
faces pressed to it oh my god
right yeah yeah it just sounds like
oh god
we went to like the gregory brothers
concert and we went i went the wrong way
because no one was like ushering us a
different world people like literally
like grabbed us and pulled us back out
of the group
and then we like i i went with like matt
and ryan from super mega one year right
and we walked around the back and we
were out like in the apartment area of
it and walking around and some fan was
like i had like a hat i had a mask i had
my hood up and somebody was like oh i
knew it was you from your walk
i was like this is
that's oh my god i never walked in a
video
i'm like how did you recognize me so
after that i was like
maybe don't do vidcon again right yeah
because that's pretty much the
experience we've heard and that's like
it's it's a convention where
you know as a youtuber you think you
need to go to at least once but every
youtuber i've talked to has been like
you know you don't need to go to vidcon
yeah pax was great though i have so many
fond memories of pax and like right i
wanted to seem all negative like all my
interactions were bad but yeah yeah
people at pax were absolutely i thought
about packs yeah yeah and they would
they'd wait in line for like seven hours
and be starving and just for a chance to
like talk to you and then i was so sweet
and talk about how much you changed
their life and everything
and we were like those would always go
on it was like scheduled for two hours
and they'd go on for like five because
yeah you just want to actually meet
these people yeah interactions they're
all lovely yeah i mean like hearing you
say that people in europe and people in
the uk are a lot chiller compared to
people in america like terrifies the
[ __ ] out of me because we just went to a
convention last weekend and uh literally
in that one convention like a random guy
just went up on stage on on our panel
and sat next to joey and that was like
to me like i'd never dealt with anything
like that in my life extremely
traumatized
so i'm just like if it's like that in
the uk uh how is it gonna be like in
literally the first one we've done so
like it's now or never yeah yeah so it's
it's basically like a learning it's been
like a learning experience for us as
well did you go to indie popcorn is that
one that you want to see okay i think i
went the year after you
and it was like it was like this really
weird thing where it was like we do not
talk about what happened
genuinely it'd be like yeah indie pop
got all the stuff like yeah it's been
really good working except for last year
yeah we had markiplier and jack in the
same building and it was like
they said that they were basically i'd
the message that i heard maybe you can
confirm i just want to know this
personally i don't give a [ __ ]
they basically said that like they were
extremely woefully unprepared is the
message that i heard
yeah we we went i was like 2015 or 2016.
i can't remember yeah and it was the
second convention i ever went to and
it was me mark bob and wade all like in
a line and people
all day just lined up to meet us some
people come back multiple times we
didn't have like a
like a way
to figure it out right people were just
coming endlessly like the first day we
signed for nine hours
we had no food no breaks no anything
then the next day we went again
and over like the three day weekend we
did 21 hours of signing did they never
cap the line or anything like that there
was no capping there was no like lottery
system to let people in like everyone
was lovely but it was like we just
didn't know what to do with it yeah yeah
nine hours oh my gosh i can't even like
fathom that
like just get to the convention sign all
day go to dinner and then do it again
for two more days
it was it was brutal yeah because like i
guess was is that like a common
experience with conventions with you
especially in the early days because i
feel like with you being part of like
the early generation of youtubers where
you know you started seeing the massive
reach that you did a lot of people were
just like i from what i've heard just
didn't didn't expect you guys to like
have the reach or just have the fan
engagement that you did yeah yeah
because it was at indy popcon they have
a lot of like
like movie stars and like yeah yeah yeah
they they do signings where it's paid
for right right so we were like you
don't want to charge fans to like meet
us like yeah i wouldn't pay to meet me
yeah so
we'll just do it for free and like let
people come so it was like anybody who
was anybody was like there if they
wanted to meet someone but didn't want
to pay right some of those people didn't
even know who we were they were like
someone will know right i just came up
to like take pictures and stuff yeah
because i guess like the even back then
especially back then as well like i
think just the general consensus of like
famous youtubers being at a con was just
like oh yeah you know they just like
make videos online you know how famous
could they possibly be you know compared
to like these like people who have been
in hollywood and tv and stuff like that
yeah and uh little d i guess indie
popcorn no yeah yeah we kept like
sniping people from those lines and then
all the people who had paid signings got
mad at us and were like yeah that's
happening right yeah they're like giving
it away for free like of course no one's
going to come to my booth now and i'm
like i just want to have fun man
some of them do charge like outrageous
prices yeah it was ridiculous like 80
pounds for an autograph and it's like
what and you didn't even like really get
to meet them for very long it was like
an autograph and a picture and then buy
yeah yeah don't pay for that
i don't think anyone's worth that
you're better than that
yeah because i i feel like i i don't
know how it would be in japan but i feel
like there's very much like
a culture in japan where you you might
very much like pay for something to get
to see this celebrity or this idol
definitely like idol culture right
the illustrious handshake events
yeah yeah i saw the weirdest thing
actually now that you say that in japan
where
i
we were like next to a theater um it
wasn't like i don't think it was like a
kabuki theater or whatever it was
there's like a term for it and i can't
remember what it is
um like a traditional theater type of
thing it was like
god i'm trying to like find the words
without seeming offensive
it was like it's fine it's fine it's
fine yeah oh wow yeah i think it was
like a thing where like ladies would
dress up as like guys and like have like
really impressive music
um
yeah yeah
yeah yeah and we we were our hotel was
like right next to a takarazuka theater
and there was like dozens of people
lined up outside every evening and
people would come out and just like say
hi and they were all in line they all
like stood up one by one all perfectly
in unison it was like a swim team like
perfectly cool like swimming
but they were like they were so
respectful and they were like let's not
do anything on our end like piss them
off or they'll never do this again yeah
and they would come out and they would
like wave to everybody down the line all
the way and there was that would happen
for like a couple of hours and then
everyone would like everyone would leave
and then they were like okay we're done
like fan club go home right right fan
culture in japan is like next level yeah
yeah take it to like the limit yeah yeah
or what is it
theater so takarazuka is like it's this
basically it's like very true i don't
know a whole lot about it myself but
basically it's been around for i think
close to like a century and it's this
like specific type of uh as you said is
a specific type of like stage
performance thing that has like very
high regard and high like royalty status
basically right of like yeah basically
like really acclaims uh female stage
actresses
dress up basically they kind of cross
play yeah as like males and you know
it's it's kind of like think of like if
i don't know a traditional shakespearean
play was happening but all of the stage
performers are female yeah so all the
all the guy characters are female all
the female female female characters are
female yeah and it's uh yeah it's like
kind of a musical stage player kind of
thing um very very popular in japan for
a very specific demographic i feel like
yeah um mostly like you know kind of
like women between ages like 20 to 50
are like right right
um but yeah it was cool though like it's
really cool yeah yeah some of them would
still come out with like some of the
makeup still on it was really impressive
and then we like looked it up like when
we went back to the hotel to figure out
what's going on and like the outfits are
insane the choreography is insane yeah a
lot of money goes into it it's yeah like
some of the highest paid like stage
performers i think in the world
yeah like but i i just couldn't get my
head around it i was like trying to
figure out what it was mm-hmm it just
looked like
yeah i'm just i'm not a horrible piece
of [ __ ] i swear
please don't cancel me
i don't know how many takasuka fans we
have watching this show you know i feel
the demographic is very different the
one person who knows what you're talking
about just raises their hand yeah it's
like um actually i work in tongasson
i've tapped into that niche
you're gonna subscribers are just gonna
go up
would you ever want to go back to japan
oh yeah definitely yeah we we wanna go
like we were gonna say as soon as the
the borders open for like casual
visitors
apparently it happened like very
recently yeah and then it's and it's
already shut down yeah yeah but then i
was like it's coming up the summer i
don't really want to be there yeah yeah
you don't want to be there you don't
want to be there i mean again that's why
we're here right now so that we're not
there yeah yeah like because my again my
girlfriend lived there for like seven
years so she was like
oh and she kept trying to like warn
felix yeah i've been trying to warn
felix
is like oh no i love summer
you're not going to after this yeah i
like even for me because like i like i'm
thai so i've spent a lot of my life in
thailand i thought i will i'm prepared
for japanese summer i know what a hot
humid southeast asian countries like
it's going to be fine and i remember
spending my first year my first summer
in japan and i wanted to die nothing
like nothing even from like thailand had
prepared me for japanese summer which is
like it blows my mind because you know
in winter it's so cold there it's so
like at least in southeast asia you have
like one climate you know you have two
climates it's like hot and humid or wet
and humid you know but in japan in japan
you have like every single you know you
have every single climate on on every
single extreme of like the weather as
well so it's just
yeah japanese summers are no joke i
swear to god i went to korea for a
summer and a winter and it's the same
thing yeah just
ball sweatingly just awful yeah yeah and
i was like
reasonably cold yeah yeah i couldn't eat
my my appetite was gone and my
girlfriend was like yeah what's wrong
like are you sick and i was like i think
so like what is happening it's like it's
like walking through
like wet air yeah yeah you're just in a
sauna yeah constantly yeah yeah awful
it's like you breathe the air and it's
why is the air heavy you know it's heavy
air is there's thick air out here
and then you go into any building and
they just blast the [ __ ] out yeah it's
cold air and then you're cold yeah so
you're like oh i have to go outside to
yeah get rid of it and like it's so good
winter then it's just a complete flip of
that yeah it's like just snow everywhere
everything's hard and icy and the wind
just stabs you in the chest
and then you go inside you're sweating
yeah yeah the struggles of being from
like this part of the world yeah any any
weather is like what the [ __ ]
i mean it's not mild
22 degrees
what is happening that's why this
weekend was such a shock to me because
everyone because you know this was only
my second time in the uk yeah and
everyone was like when i when i tweeted
out saying i'm going to the uk this
weekend everyone was like enjoying the
weather
because it's going to be [ __ ] yeah
meanwhile it was like amazing [ __ ]
weather and i'm like this is [ __ ] to you
guys
yeah it was great really good but also
like uk is the type of place where you
can have like you know in japan you
really have to like choose your fashion
about what you wear depending on the
weather or something in the uk you're
like 90 of the time of the year like is
it quite weather or is it jacket weather
the answer is yes
like
you can get away with much less choice
into the uk compared to what you do in
japan you know definitely yeah
definitely so i mean i've seen a bunch
of clips of you speaking korean and i
think it just kind of surprises people
surprised me yeah because you just don't
expect people to just hey i speak some
korean hangover
i don't
i know enough to like like trick people
into thinking that i know way more
that's how it is with every foreign
language though yeah yeah we had some
friends we moved to japan recently and
they don't know any japanese and they
think i know more a lot more than i do
just because you can get through the the
kind of standard flow of conversation
right where it's like you know what
they're going to ask and what they're
going to say right for all i know you
could have just said i want to follow
you yeah yeah yeah i don't know
leave a comment
sometimes you know people like what are
they just saying i'm like i don't have a
[ __ ] clue but i have a rough idea
right i mean a lot of it is like body
language as well right yeah that was the
thing like when i went to korea i
well i i went to korea because i i met a
girl online from korea like it was like
a pen pal it's called interpals right it
was like international pen pals and i
just i just dropped out of college for
like sound engineering and i was like i
don't know what the [ __ ] i'm doing my
life i hate it
maybe i'll take a gap year what am i
going to do travel i don't want to go
anywhere and then doing that was like oh
here's a part of the world
like asia had always kind of like
fascinated me for the longest time yeah
and i like lost was out they had like
korean actors in it and i was like god
the language is so cool i want to meet
people from korea and talk to them and
then one thing led to another and we
started like dating right then i went to
visit her a few times and
and right now i was like i i don't know
what i was doing i don't know what i
expected so you watched lost and you
thought that sounds cool and that's yeah
you started learning korean yeah wow how
many years you've been studying before
like kind of roughly talking it it was
like four years back then oh wow it was
from like 20 to like
20
it was like around like 19 to 23ish
23-ish
lessons or just literally just talking
all of my own wow right right we would
like talk to each other on like
instant messenger and stuff and it was a
lot of it was all it was like
like romanized like korean yeah yeah
yeah like the actual alphabet it was
just her writing stuff in english right
and i would learn it so much faster that
way and i
i think i just picked up on things
quickly anyway that's good yeah and then
when i went there was like oh [ __ ] now i
get everything because [ __ ] textbooks
are always like
can you point me to the nearest embassy
it's like hello this is a pen
yeah so being there it was like it was
all like body language and like seeing
how they emoted and yeah yeah yeah yeah
and like just being surrounded by the
alphabet and like seeing it on stores
and trying to read it all the time it
just it accelerates things so much
faster uh yeah when we had kevin on
kevin speaks some pretty good japanese
and uh he said the best way that he
learned was just getting drunk
and trying to speak it yeah yeah and uh
yeah i think that helped me a lot with
japanese as well yeah just getting drunk
because yeah you don't care that you're
[ __ ] up yeah yeah i i would just kind
of like be in her house with her family
and they would have like
like in like running man and stuff and i
was like i have no idea what's going on
but you can just you can tell what's
happening just through body language
right like pick up words here and there
from what i knew
yeah you got trapped in the deep end
then yeah yeah these are my parents
talk to them oh my god
and i made like the oh the worst mistake
which is like not putting yo at the end
of words because i got so casual with
her right right right
and then i was like
and then she was like
and i was like i'm never speaking this
to you
i [ __ ] up the most basic thing ever my
manners were out the window but
it was a cool learning experience i
think it matured me very quickly right
seeing like another part of the world i
was like
i think that's what i've learned over
youtube like seeing so many like races
ethnicities genders yeah like skin
colors like religious beliefs i was like
yeah it like broadens your world so fast
that you can't like internalize your
problems to just yourself anymore yeah
do you think learning korean has helped
helped you like say understand their
culture more when you were over there
because i i feel like i feel like we've
had this discussion before but i feel
like part of a culture is ingrained in
their language and you might be able to
like
sympathize with some culture but like
empathizing with them through like
language is just like a different
different level i think yeah because
they have like honorific systems and
everything and like treating older
people a certain way and i that
obviously isn't ingrained in our yeah
yeah
yeah
um
[Laughter]
like yes we can't yeah we don't do we
really no no no it's completely
different yeah
yeah do you speak any uh gaelic at all
not really no i i speak welsh and
there's there's a kind of honorific
system you're fluent in welsh yeah i'm
native yeah i went to wash schools and
uh did all my exams in welsh
what is like how are you in welsh city
um it's connoisseur tattoo and irish oh
okay so i'm trying to see like where the
connection is but we have so many l's
and stuff right we have the
[Applause]
before the end of this podcast you'll be
able to bust your flex
in welsh there's the honorifics of kind
of like how casual do you speak to them
whereas you say t
or d
uh yeah i i'm so bad at irish that i
wouldn't even be able to tell yeah we
learned it in school but like no one
really speaks it enough in the part of
ireland that i was in unless you're
studying it right yeah yeah i think i
don't know if i i think welsh language
they the government tries their goddamn
hardest to get more fluency right it's
taken like really seriously in wales and
they're really like passionate about it
it seems that ireland they still are but
not to the same extent yeah the west of
ireland is pretty i guess wales is west
in the
region of the country yeah yeah yeah i i
think i don't know i think just because
not enough people speak it and we've
integrated into the world better
like english i think yeah
i don't know i shouldn't speak about my
own culture because i'm so
unknowledgeable about it
in ireland all the road signs in gaelic
end yeah i said well it's the same all
in welsh and english and like on the
coins there's like irish on them and
yeah right like notes and stuff so we
have some of it there but we're not like
reinforcing it very well right right
yeah i found out that the uh the uh mint
for all the english money is in wales
and i thought how did they let that
happen why why haven't we taken it all
yeah like we need some of it well
there's not there's none of it in wales
yeah
if ireland had that we would have got
the republic
yeah say it again
i did yeah i'm surprised you in scotland
didn't like rise up
actually the worst part is that wales
was like very much
for it even though wales benefited so
much from uh getting uh help from the eu
but it was a mess it was it's a sad time
many people knew what was going on
i was actually at that vidcon that i was
talking about in la when it happened
that must have been oh really we're
going to a party in the news broke and
we were like oh time to drink
let's forget about that i feel like it
became it was it was about brexit but it
was about so much more different things
for the voters than yeah what it
actually was about as it has become and
uh yeah yeah it's it's not that yeah i
mean i remember i was in in america at
the time as well uh i was staying at uh
my you know now fiance's place and uh
yeah
he's getting married
it's your birthday hey it's my birthday
today
all right that's all you get though yeah
okay
um and yeah i remember like seeing it on
the news and i'm just like it was like
50 50 and i'm like i'm gonna go to bed
and like when i wake up i'll wake up to
like the good news
and i remember still like waking up
seeing on my phone and i'm just like
i must've like been dreaming of like
obviously seeing this wrong and i'm like
like refresh refresh my brain and i just
stared at it for like a good like two
minutes and i just couldn't [ __ ]
believe it expand the top like inception
yeah yeah yeah
doesn't just become [ __ ] yeah and yeah
in the youtube space it doesn't really
affect us
yeah unless you're importing vegetables
[ __ ]
my coffee doesn't ship to england as
easily now oh okay i actually want to
ask you about that why coffee yeah why
is that the is it to kind of stand out
you were like [ __ ] it no yeah because
like cloak makes sense right because you
know that's that's the thing that that's
a move i think that youtubers have been
trying to make for a very i mean yeah i
also made that move as well yeah like
the coffee thing i think no one was
expecting yeah i
i just really liked coffee for a really
long time and i initially was like
thinking of whiskey
and i was like oh that would have been
something yeah youtuber whiskey yeah
yeah and i it's just so much harder like
there's actually laws around it yeah
yeah
my audience probably wouldn't even like
40 of them probably wouldn't even be
able to drink it right right getting
into different places would be
impossible and then i was like i kept
thinking about coffee and i was like
what if we made like top of the morning
coffee
i was like okay that [ __ ] name is too
good i have to do it yeah okay yeah and
then it was a part of that like nobody
else was doing it and i was like it sets
me apart from other people and it's
different they're just doing merch and
clothes right right it's just a fun
thing that i had no idea about and like
learning how it was made and
that i just had my own coffee yeah i
could if it's the stains itself i get
free coffee all the time yeah yeah yeah
extremely successful i assume yeah thank
you
thank you i get free coffee every day
was there any was any like challenges
that you didn't anticipate starting a
company like this that has like nothing
to do with youtube yeah it's initially
it was like coffee's like a food item
yeah it's it has to be shipped as fresh
and quick as possible right so when we
started the shipping to england was a
nightmare because we have to pay import
charges and everything right and it
would take like a month to get it to
people right and then it would cost
extra so shipping here costs like twice
as much as the coffee itself right um
and it was like starting a company you
have to start really small especially
when it's something that you haven't
done before and we had no like
infrastructure really for it initially
so we it's it's made in like uh
in america and it's made in like
nebraska and stuff yeah it was shipping
from there and that was the only place
it was shipping from so we had to figure
out a new method to get it to people
cheaper right we thankfully did and all
that feedback initially was like really
really helpful yeah but as soon as it
went up everyone was super pumped about
it and then all that day i was miserable
because everyone was like this [ __ ]
sucks it's so expensive it doesn't ship
here you don't right
yeah yeah yeah like the sight went down
and i spent the whole day being like man
i spent so long like prepping this and
then you're so like emotionally attached
to it yeah like trying to like put out
fires all day yeah yeah no matter how
much you make your merch though there's
always that oh it's too expensive yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah i mean we don't have this like
gigantic west system in every single
town yeah walmart we can't just get [ __ ]
to you extremely well that was the thing
is like trying to educate people while
also like sympathizing with
trying to meet them halfway with
everything and yeah
like not trying not to get too businessy
with them right
listen the breakdown costs right you
understand
our profit and loss
we're in debt yeah well like i guess i i
wanna like as a youtuber how do you even
like start to like
like how like okay yeah yeah yeah
because you guys okay because like i
think okay but maybe like one day maybe
we'll start like the trash taste coffee
company i don't know what it's going to
be called but like okay so there i'll
i'll just phone my coffee gu
who do i do who's the coffee guy who do
i talk to
yeah yeah yeah like where where did you
even like start
yeah did you just like meet a dude who
was like oh by the way i'm very
interested in starting a coffee company
well there was a company that was doing
it with brooke dodger right oh okay they
were doing it with smosh as well
um and that was another thing like a
review for the coffee came out and
somebody was like it was like a big
coffee guy on youtube and i have his
book he taught me so much about coffee
and i thought he was great and then he
was like youtubers getting into coffee
what does the business look like
and it was all like he didn't actually
start his own coffee company like he
used this other company to like source
the beans and everything and i was like
yeah i said that like
i don't think i was dishonest like did
people think i was going to like go to
the farm myself and like
change
business videos if you're just like
touching the beans yeah just like yeah
handpicked by jackson
like i did start a company that has like
its own official documents and yeah i
don't i didn't like buy a roastery on my
own roasters
like i think they expected a bit more
out of it
yeah yeah yeah but yeah they were like
handling coffee for people already and
we were
my agents at the time were like they
they just do everything for everybody
right right right um and they they kind
of knew a couple of people who were
certain coffee companies already and
they were like we can put you in touch
with all these people and then uh akira
coffee who are doing the one that is
we're working with now they had done
dodgers and when i talked to them they
just seemed so genuine and nice and open
about it and they they got it and it
wasn't all about like cranking money out
of people and right right it was just
really honest like
genuine fun to do so now the question is
how did dodger get in touch with her
yeah we'll go back the line
we'll work our way up yeah exactly but
technically yeah i had a coffee guide
today
okay okay definitely makes things a lot
easier there's always somebody you know
who knows somebody you know right put
you in touch with the right people yeah
and if not you can always just tweet it
out
hey i want to find someone on the
theater yeah
see like i've tried that a few times
where you're just like you need a guy
and like you tweet it out you know is
this is there any
and and like you get everything but that
guy
you you most of the tweets are just like
i don't i'm not the guy but good luck
and i'm just like why why are you
replying to this twitter thread it's
always like i'm not that guy but i do
have a fiverr account i can make you
some artwork for it if that's okay with
you and i'm like thanks but no here's my
fan cam that i did
[Laughter]
yeah
that was cool though one thing i want to
know
right is why did you decide to move to
brighton because i i want to know this
is a brighton resident well i i want to
know this as someone who was born and
raised in brighton and like you know i
grew up that's cool yeah yeah yeah so
you know i you know still technically
live in brighton
yeah um
yeah i like i remember when brighton was
a town it wasn't even a city it was a
town and now seeing
like growing up and now seeing you know
big youtubers coming there and like it's
the cool city it's a cool hip city like
i want to know like you personally since
you being such a big presence there in
terms like content creators who have
moved to brighton what made you decide
to do so
i think because felix lived there for a
long time and i'd heard really nice
things from him and then like alfie and
those guys were there and there was a
couple of other like big a lot of them
were those right right there and i
didn't really get it it
when i got when i went there i realized
oh it's like a mini la now i kind of get
it right right right sort of like
structure but smaller
and i went there to visit him for the
first time over like a weekend in
october like years and years ago and
then i just fell in love with it
immediately because i i've been thinking
about moving already and i was like la
is a bit too far yeah crazy yeah you
have to get visas and everything and i
was like i kind of maybe london and then
london is just a [ __ ] nightmare
it's the traffic's awful there's too
many people here it's just it was a bit
too busy for someone who grew up in a
tiny town and then we went to brighton i
was like this is lovely this is like
small the beach is there if we wanted my
friends are there feeling so prideful
right now man i'm feeling so frightful
i'm like yeah it is yeah it is
the people were just so nice and like it
was like a really strong like lgbtq yeah
yeah yeah there and everybody was just
so like progressive and nice the vegan
community was huge there yeah and i was
like this is perfect why would i live
anywhere else yeah just walking around
town was a very walkable city and it was
just really fun to do if you don't get
like bombarded do you feel like walking
around town no really oh wow okay
everyone's pretty chill in brighton oh
yeah i mean people come up and ask for
pictures and stuff but if you say no
they're like yeah okay
yeah because it was it was really weird
for me because
uh obviously now that uh i came back
from
you know living in japan for two years
and we started this podcast and before
that i like didn't show my face on
camera and like for the first time i
started to get recognized in this home
city that i like grew up in yeah so like
like like i would have thought that you
would have gotten recognized a lot or it
would have been like a daily occurrence
so yeah i think initially when i moved
it probably was but then now people know
you're there they kind of right like
there's no sense of emergency you're
right right right right right some
people still have to like you look
familiar but then they don't really go
any further than that
yeah i guess like different
sensibilities as well yeah like
yeah versus america yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah people here aren't as starstruck
yeah i don't think so you guys
brighton's a cool city come visit
brighton it's an amazing city no don't
you'll ruin it
it's nice i like it
don't make it to vidcon
yeah we we thought about that for a
while as well like maybe we'll move to
la still and
brighton's just nice every time we come
back it's like man we have a nice house
we live in a nice part of town yeah
people are cool the restaurants are
really nice yeah like la just seems
intense you know from my experience with
it it's it's two city i feel and
especially like it's definitely the
culture behind it is definitely you know
i feel run by this like you know stardom
culture it's a big marauder yeah exactly
exactly it doesn't really because i i
said it before that when i went on tour
you get a good sense of like life in
different pockets of the world yeah yeah
yeah and then like going around
different states i was like oh this is
kind of like that state but you guys do
this instead and you kind of get a feel
for the culture a bit everything still
felt like quintessentially america yeah
yeah but then la is just a different
beast like it it feels like we would go
down the streets and like walk around
and you can get a sense for the place
like who's walking around and who lives
there and like they're they're just a
slice of life yeah but la is so hard to
find that with yeah anywhere you walk in
it which is very few places it feels
like everyone's just there to work yeah
no one like lives there yeah yeah like
every time i meet like someone in l.a
you just get used to people introducing
themselves than saying what they do
immediately you know normally that's
like
a few layers down in the conversation
but in la it feels like okay i'm this
person by the way i also do this i'm
working on this this this and that's
just like i that was just like very
forward for me sorry yeah
yeah working on screenplays
propositioned one in an uber well in
l.a then
on the same trip we heard a guy walking
down the street it's like i just don't
think they're going to go for that
screenplay maybe if we pitched on this
other one i was like no [ __ ] way
people talk like this
it was i was like in a movie
walk on set
yeah you're in like the traffic and
there's someone like practicing their
lines and like the car next to you or
something
yeah because you hear horror stories of
people who move there and then like
change and become hollywood yeah yeah
yeah i think it's impossible not to i
that was another thing i was kind of
afraid to move there in case i didn't
come this monster yeah yeah he just
because i'm a sponge i'll just take in
what's around me and i'm yeah like if
i'm surrounded by that all the time
that's all you know and yeah yeah it's
very disconnected from the rest of the
world i feel like when we come back here
and we live here it's like people don't
talk the same they're not talking about
stocks all the time
like investing in houses
[Laughter]
yeah
i think that's like another big reason
why like i probably could never see
myself living in a place like that
because it's like yeah again like i
don't want to be that guy yeah you know
who who turns into that right yeah yeah
and yeah like you know i love all the
people i love all my friends who live in
l.a for sure they're all amazing people
but you know at the same time yeah it is
kind of like
another world yeah it doesn't feel real
i mean i have so many friends there and
so many of them just complain about l.a
all the time like they don't even want
to be there yeah they can't leave yeah
yeah it's hard to get out well it's it's
the best place for this type of work
yeah yeah it is never more productive
than when i go to l.a yeah it's true
sure there's always something that you
could be working on yeah yeah yeah
infinite connections right yeah i feel
like if you want to network then you
know la is the place to be yeah uh but
at what cost
is there no part of you that ever wanted
to try living in korea for a bit
i don't think so i think it's too much
of a culture
[Music]
and i i'm a very social person and i
feel like i would not integrate as much
as i would want to right i feel like i
would be very scared and nervous to like
speak korean to people and
i would never go out and like join like
a book club or go meet people at like an
event or anything right right right
right church would you scary would you
ever
are you planning to i guess like stay in
like uk and ireland then do you see
yourself like
sticking around this kind of area i
think i think it's nice enough i think
if we've carved out like a knife a nice
niche yeah like place for us here and
yeah i think again it keeps me very like
grounded and keeps me like very in touch
with the world yeah and like walking
around here and in brighton i feel like
i'm actually like a part of like the
bigger picture yeah yeah i know that's
awesome it doesn't feel like a bubble
like everywhere else but i i've done la
for like three months at one point and
it was really fun i had a lot of friends
there and like every night was something
to hang out with yeah so many good
restaurants in l.a
yeah yeah that is one thing that every
time i go back to la i'm looking forward
to the restaurant and foods it's like
the only place outside of korea that has
good korean barbecue yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
you so good rainbow is really good yeah
i'm so excited for that like because
we're going to la actually in about
like two weeks two three weeks i'm
recording yeah yeah yeah from the time
of this recording and the first place i
always want to hit up is the korean
barbecue of course yeah you can eat meat
it's just insane yeah
you get it in japan it's like yeah it's
all you can eat maybe maybe if you're
lucky and we're nice but probably korean
bbq i feel is very different to like
yakiniku yeah yeah yeah it is
yeah yeah it is both amazing but it's
like it's it's definitely a different
vibe yeah yeah yeah do you have any
favorite korean dishes or just any
favorite like food in general
um i mean i'm a sucker for just a good
piping pop
oh god yeah like a proper korean one
like the stone bowl yeah yeah it's still
crackling as it comes yeah it's just
really good and it's nice and spicy and
warm and like it's good winter food but
there's there's also another one called
i think it's so long tang which is like
it's like a oxbone broth
yeah i've had that once it's
very tasty it's it's tasty and it just
like it's it cleans the soul that's what
it feels like i remember i remember one
time like i was like like one of the
most hungover i've ever been in korea
yeah i felt awful and had like the
the the ox bone soup and it just felt
like my body was just like so refreshed
afterwards i don't know i don't know
what you guys put in there but like
it's like the ancient herbal like
like the ancient herbal medicine that
they like that everyone talks about
that's what it felt like
yeah i'm a big fan of like a mandu chige
which is like a dumpling stew as well
okay okay any of those like it's like
stuff that i wouldn't get here really
and i was like yeah
it's so good there's probably a lot of
stuff that you can't really get here
right yeah at least not proper yeah and
i'm afraid i still stand by the korean
food's my favorite food in the world i
love korean food i love these yeah
korean fried chicken is also [ __ ]
incredible i don't realize that koreans
have perfected fried chicken it's the
best yeah i have the best i i think
koreans have the best fried chicken in
the world yeah to be fair i don't think
i've ever heard or met anyone who has
said that they don't like korean food so
yeah it's pretty difficult haven't had
it that's a lot of this yeah well they
haven't had the good one yeah yeah but
yeah because i guess like korean food
wasn't as popular i guess like uh like
10 years ago or something because i
remember like i never even tried korean
food until around like 10 about like 10
years ago and then because it was all
like you know you see like indian food
or like japanese food or chinese food
and like i never got a chance to try
korean cuisine and then remember the
first time trying it i was like why is
this not more more popular you know why
is this not more widespread
yeah k-pop are doing a lot of the heavy
lifting on that yes yes yes spreading
into the world
which is great because now we have like
a good uh korean restaurant in brighton
called kogi which is just me yeah
um but it does like legit korean food
yeah cool so good
i gotta check it out i think that's new
is it is it new since uh or is it been
around for a while um i think it was
right before pandemic and i'm so happy
that pandemic didn't kill it okay
because i was very worried i was like
you haven't been open long enough to
like have a float of cash yeah yeah
survive this but i think they're still
going strong yeah because i feel like in
brighton now there's just like like
there's been a lot of restaurants been
popping up now because when i because i
i obviously moved out brighton like
about like just before pandemic and even
then i wasn't really living in brighton
as well i was more living in thailand so
just seeing like one thing that i've
learned from japan is i love food
culture i love restaurant culture and i
come back to brighton and now there's
like every cuisine under the sun there's
like cool restaurants and i'm like [ __ ]
yes yeah yeah so like another thing i
guess uh that you've been doing a lot
recently is the whole touring thing
right yeah and uh as someone who well as
we're about to do our very first tour
like i want to know as like
the the upperclassman like oh you know
the experienced one of tours
like is the senpai yeah the senpai of
tours
is is there uh like any i guess like how
how different is it to like say you know
a regular convention or like really like
anything
um it's
so much better than regular content
it's like because like well this is
great because you actually have people
to like talk to yeah yeah yeah yeah and
joke around with but when you're on your
own and you're recording a let's play
and it's like am i funny nope
and then you're just waiting for the
camera to laugh back and it doesn't
like when i went on tour i came back and
i was miserable because i was like i
don't know how to make videos anymore
i'm just by myself and nothing i'm
saying is funny
i think some of that still lingers
around today but it's such a
fun electric energy and i was doing them
like every day and going out to a show
and seeing so many parts of the world
and again food culture is such a massive
part the best part of tour is everything
between your show because i i had a
really good tour family and everyone was
very mature and no
like
there was no like egos anywhere and
everyone was just so nice and i got to
know them so well man the fact that you
call it a family another team just says
like like they say they're tall team
this they say this is the family family
vin diesel
[Laughter]
we because you just spend everyone's
like sleeping on the bus and you all
kind of like you're in such close
proximity to each other right if any if
any ego is there you'll know it
immediately right and everyone will get
on each other's nerves but we just have
so much fun going to restaurants and
like oh this is the biggest restaurant
in the city let's go there and yeah we
would hang out and just drink after the
shows or go to a place like a day early
we went to florida and i got to see like
universal and um
harry potter land there awesome awesome
just like most of my best memories are
probably from tour
what's like the wildest location that
you remember from like any of your tours
where it's like i want to go back and do
a show there or like i want to go back
there to like experience you know what i
experienced during you know pre or post
show yeah the the weirdest one i think
was new orleans which sorry
neolins which wasn't selling well
initially and then they were like oh
they're a musical town like they'll show
up on the day and they'll buy tickets at
the door right and then i got there and
they didn't so half the theater was
empty it was like daylight out i could
see everybody and it was like people
were yelling at each other in the crowd
at each other
during the show yeah being like you're
great somebody else being like shut the
[ __ ] up he's doing a show be like no you
shut the [ __ ] up
and i was like
i'm probably remembering it far more
like hyperbolic yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah that was like new orleans is such a
weird town because there's a place
called the french quarter i think and
that was like like all the old-timey
buildings and like what you think new
orleans looks like right that area of
the world and it was like right after
mardi gras right so
like still celebrating that right
then it was just like it was almost like
a line in the sand and then suddenly
it's just metropolis right so it was
like going from old to new immediately
and all these people out in the streets
all having fun and there was like a
death museum there and we had like
crawfish and then i had snails for the
first time there and i was like it was
all these like experiences back to back
where i was right i'm not wait pause
what the hell is a death museum where
you go and like look at stuff about like
dead bodies and pieces of like
that not just the cemetery
no you get to see them
it's like a cemetery with windows
at the end you join the museum
it's just like a lot of stuff about like
the history of like death and like
medical culture and how they discover
stuff pretty sure the history of death
goes all the way to the start of
humanity you know
you can go all the way to the end
you know this this guy isaac death
discovered death and humanity just was
never the same again
he brought it upon everyone
that was a weird experience so it was
just a lot of like crazy [ __ ] happening
but then the i think the coolest one was
probably florida because i got to do it
in universal so i was like wow it was
like the hard rock cafe in universal wow
so i kept hearing like we're doing the
hard rock cafe and i was like those are
a big deal and then we were like walking
around universal and i was like is the
hard rock i'm doing like bigger than
this they're like that is the one you're
doing oh wow so you actually have to
like go into like the start of universal
to see it wow
people outside of it and i think there
was something about it like it was the
first one or it was the biggest one in
the world like the hard rock right and
then we got like a private tour around
it and got to see like the upper area
where like paul mccartney stuff was like
awesome oh my god
elvis stuff was like lying around
i was like okay that's pretty cool that
sounds awesome
doing it and like the floor design of
that one was like a perfect like
like semi-circle and like i was able to
talk to everyone perfectly acoustics
were great yeah
the show slapped harder than it did in
most places
what did you do in the shows i i did a
mix of like stand up with like small
snippets of gameplay in it so that's
right it was like a story about my life
done in a stand-up comedy way where i
would tell stories of my past with like
punch lines and everything right but
then it was like broken up into three
acts where i would have like act one
would be like my childhood and here's
where i grew up and everything about
that and then i played a modded pokemon
blue because that was the first game i
remember getting that i loved right but
the game the characters in it like we
set it up that you fought your rival you
had to fight six pokemon but all six
were named after like
like
like
hard things in your life like fear
right that's cool and then the last one
was called rent
so we'd bring someone up on stage to
play it and then give them a chance to
like be a youtuber for like
20 minutes and then we'd move on to like
my teenage years and that was like when
i was like depressed and lived in a
cabin in the woods and was miserable and
kind of like just sort of like relate to
the audience and then the last one was
we play shadow of the colossus for that
one because i discovered that game
during that period right and then
someone came up and played that and then
adulthood was all about youtube and
where i went from there and how i
uplifted myself out of that and then we
played happy wheels on stage because
of course it's the most hyped game to
play live ever yeah right um but the
whole point of the show was to kind of
like relate the story of my life
entertaining wise but to show them like
here's where i came from here's what i
did nothing is special i'm nobody yeah
here i am like doing it yeah how do you
make sure a show doesn't suck
i don't know [ __ ] because we were hoping
you'd tell us about that
yeah you do do you write the show and
then you're like [ __ ] it's not funny how
do i make it you call up screenwriters
in l.a
help me out bro well i call up uber
drivers
i did it with real good touring was like
brent and aaron and those guys oh yeah
yeah we're doing it as well yeah yeah so
i i like brought out the structure of it
and they were like so can you perform it
for us and i did practice shows to like
400 people in like chicago and stuff and
i did it and i was like
okay it's a show finally
like i never i never wrote out the jokes
properly i kind of just improv i had
like
like pillars to hint right like
yeah yeah yeah and then as the show
progressed i got better and better at it
and like trimmed the fat a little and
yeah but it'll work because you guys
know each other so well you've been
around each other so long and you you
bounce like the same humor off each
other so
hopefully maybe yeah you're right
how much like how much planning went
into like i guess not like the actual
like planning the logistics but like the
content of the tour
or the show narrative yeah how long how
long does that take to like i think for
me it was like four months wow but i i
kind of knew what i wanted going into it
like i i had the idea to do because
burnham had released make happy at the
time right especially before inside and
i was like i want to do something like
that where it's like i always wanted to
try stand up anyway i didn't want to get
up and do what i always do but kind of a
little bit to like pander to the
audience with the games and stuff right
um but i wanted it to make sense in it
but the whole point was that i wanted to
do something fun but have like a message
at the end of it right right right um
and the final line of the show was like
go out and be the heroes of your own
story and like empower people to like do
the thing because everyone looks at this
stuff and they're like how did you do it
who do you know they like got you here
and like pewdiepie shout out and all
this stuff and right they think that
like these specific steps need to happen
right
i grew up in a town of 600 people and
knew nothing about the world and i
[ __ ] up tons of times along the way
and i was miserable and depressed and
hated myself and failed college and then
i was like
i still got up and like talk to people
on the stage yeah
like anybody can do it really yeah yeah
yeah yeah you make it sound a lot easier
it's a different type of show you don't
have to get up and have that specific
true truth yeah yeah i mean you sound
like it was it sounds like an amazing
show with an amazing amount of
preparation and content that's going
into it you know what you wanted to do
yeah yeah and i'm saying listening i'm
sitting here listening being like guys
um so he set the standard but you know
don't uh don't don't expect that
please
yeah the tour did a lot for me yeah
well reynolds is in the audience
i feel like i'm just a good bullshitter
i feel like i can get up and like talk
isn't that youtuber
youtuber i feel like i can like talk
myself out of any scenario so right i
feel like i i really enjoy life stuff
and i enjoy a lot more than uh like
scripted stuff doesn't really play that
well with me
um do you enjoy live streaming much no
that's so odd so you enjoy live stuff
but not like because i can't hear them
by live you mean like the feedback yeah
yeah and it's like you're in the space
and everyone's there for a specific
energy and if like we had a thing at the
start where i was like put away your
phones you've seen me through a screen
enough like yeah now it's not the time
to do that that's what's gonna happen to
connor after outsole this is gonna try
and go back in the live livestream if
you're like it's not the same
when i when i don't hear the pogs in
like the crowd
yeah yeah dude
maybe maybe i'll go live number this is
boring
where's the feed i want to see just have
a [ __ ] sound deck where you can
play a laugh every now and then yeah
did you
it is more fun to do it live and i feel
like
because the show wouldn't translate to a
video well
we did the documentary and everything of
it but we still pulled out so much of
the show from it because i'm like none
of these jokes land if you're not there
of course and everyone's there to giggle
and everyone's there it's like anything
you say will make them laugh and i feel
like
nothing's like taken out of context
nothing is weird about it no one like
takes something and then brings it
somewhere else yeah and i feel like live
streaming is a lot of that where i'm
like yeah i could i could say something
and you could take it out of context and
put it somewhere else and seeing people
show up i'm such a people pleaser so if
somebody says i hate this and it's one
out of like a thousand yeah yeah i'll
still see it and it'll like ruin my
whole mood
so i i just i empathize with people way
too easily and if someone's not having a
good time i'm like it's my fault i
[ __ ] it up so i'm like why am i live
why did i go live if people aren't
enjoying themselves did you get many
hecklers or anything like that you had
to deal with live
um not like bad hecklers right just
people who are enthusiastic who treated
me like a panel at a convention yeah
yeah yeah and i like lost my trail of
thought and i [ __ ] up one of the jokes
one night and said like the punchline
way too early um how do you recover from
that on stage though yeah i didn't i
just moved on
it was awful i like i like froze and i
had maybe if you do your live show
you'll have this experience because
other people i've talked to have had it
where you go on i i've done the show
like like 30 times at this point and
then at some point i was like saying the
show and i like drifted out of my body
and i was like what if i [ __ ] this up
right now and i was like i could say
anything i could say the most horrific
[ __ ] ever that would ruin everything
and then i was like wait i'm not even
paying attention to what i'm saying and
my mouth was just like saying all of the
jokes right and i was like i came back
into my body and i was like i've never
had that experience before wow wow
some therapist is like yeah you have a
condition
come come see me with my oldest yeah
well that was so bizarre how your brain
just like takes over and just works
through yeah yeah yeah which i guess
you'd probably get doing live streams
yeah i guess so yeah thinking about
dinner and everyone's in chat like
you're just making jokes though yeah you
can definitely auto pilot it after a
while i mean sometimes i do on this
podcast you know not even with a live
audience sometimes i'm just like my
mouth is like moving right now but i
don't know what point i'm trying to make
i'm just saying [ __ ] but in the back of
my mind i'm like god i gotta take a [ __ ]
do you have adhd by any chance yes i do
yes but i i actually only got recently
diagnosed actually like two months ago
hell yeah high five
i wish i could join in this flex yeah i
can't either i'm just fascinated to know
how many people who do this job have
adhd because i'm convinced that's like
yeah i think it's a lot yeah yeah every
livestream right now has adhd yeah yeah
i think it's impossible to be a
successful streamer if you don't i don't
know about that
to be honest like it's because it's
you know because it's so much stimuli
right
yeah and there's so much multitasking
yeah i guess even like at the beginning
it just felt so overwhelming you know
like you have like you you want to play
the game you want to do whatever
activity but then you have to have like
a second like like a third eye to keep
like keep an eye on the chat and
everything like that it's like
it's just do it yeah then and then it
becomes second nature yeah like i
remember when you started when you start
off it's like oh
yeah i've said this to these guys but i
i enjoy i don't really enjoy gaming if
if i'm not doing it on stream i just
feel like unless i see those like funny
little emotes popping up in the corner
of my eye i'm like some in my brain
there's a horror for content i think i
maybe i am i think i am a [ __ ] for
content i think i mean there's nothing
wrong with it yeah if i don't see that w
it doesn't get me up in the morning
something about seeing that spanish guy
laughing you know that just makes me
feel so happy i'm like i made a joke and
people laughed even though it wasn't
funny but yeah god these paid actors are
great
what you have is called a parasocial
relationship
maybe i'm parasocial yeah i'm like guys
please turn up
like making your own schedule i think
adhd people relate to
yeah definitely because like that's why
that's why to me like i could never be
like a full-time streamer i think
because you know with a stream you know
sometimes
you you always feel the pressure to
stream like certain hours you know at
least like prof like real professional
streamers where with youtube
professional streaming yeah
yeah
well but like with youtube my like my
like productivity is not like a linear
curve you know so i'll have like certain
days certain weeks where i'm just like
on it and then certain months where just
like nothing happens and i don't know
what to do about it and it just like it
goes up and down so that's one big
difference between i think youtube and
twitch streaming that i enjoy i mean you
uploaded every day
yeah with adhd yeah you basically had a
stream of schedule on youtube
yeah
i mean i i have done the streaming thing
for a while we did the server like years
ago all right call the among us crew and
i was streaming like eight hours some
days and like staying up till 6am to
play it yeah but after that i don't know
it just made me anxious to go live
yeah i feel like i can make something
more entertaining when it's
paced around editing right but if it's
me i'm like
i don't i just find myself boring you
think there's like too much down time
between like the highlights i guess i
don't know maybe maybe it's just like a
background kind of brain thing going on
right right right i don't know if that
just the feeling of having to like
please people live just kind of got to
me yeah i can imagine like because i i i
guess like i can relate because when you
feel like you do have to like always be
on it and always like be entertaining
it's just so training you know
whereas uh you know with i guess like
with the let's play you can take a break
and you just like okay this part's gonna
be edited out no pressure but when it's
live you constantly feel like you have
eyes watching you yeah plus if i stream
like you said there's a certain amount
of hours like if you stream less than
two hours everyone's like go away
but it just got in the way of other work
like there's other things i want to do
like my youtube would suffer for it and
if i'm not uploading those streams then
what's the point yeah yeah
i'm a much better youtuber than i am a
streamer right right it's not the same
skill set at all yeah despite what
people think no no definitely not yeah
going back to the tool i'm wondering
like did you find that there was like
different crowd energy in like the
different places that you went and you
had to like kind of tailor your
performance to where wherever you were
or like the energy that you felt yeah i
mean that's why i was saying how like
you can tell americans are just far more
boisterous about things right for a life
scenario that's [ __ ] amazing because
they will cheer you on to everything
they're so much like more energetic and
they're just so much more maybe they're
more attuned to live culture or
something i don't know yeah yeah yeah um
or maybe you're just loud but it's great
it made me feel awesome
um but then going to europe it was very
different because there's like some
jokes that are kind of like
like about ireland and like like being a
catholic boy and being an altar boy in
church and things like that and i think
americans relate to irish people very
much considering they all tell me
they're irish yeah yeah
but don't know any places from there
yeah
um
this factory yeah
places like france and germany like
there was language barriers and stuff
and like irish humor didn't really play
as easily people were so fun and they
had energy and they were still energetic
about it but some places laugh right
with others and then
having a joke about like i had a joke
about being an altar boy and then i was
saying like teenage years got dark or
whatever and it was like a joke about
basically hinting at like priest versus
altar boy culture right right but not
saying anything about it obviously just
letting the audience like make that
interpretation and then i was like no
not that kind of show
and people would laugh but salt lake
city did not
all the mormons like go and like big
churches right there and they were kind
of like
they were like don't like that one
do people like come up to you after the
show for example and like you know be
like oh hey you know i really liked your
show but like this joke was kind of
weird or you know because you hear about
like comedians doing that right like
after the show they'd like go into the
crowd and be like meet the fans or like
you know it turns out it's really easy
when you're not transphobic
if you're not saying racist [ __ ]
transphobic [ __ ] homophobic [ __ ] it's
real easy to like put on a show without
those jokes in there what a hot day
only the hottest steaks here on trash
um but yeah i mean my my jokes never
really went that far a lot of stuff is
about my life and my experience through
it so it's like luckily you weren't a
transphobic racist yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah life's much better when you're not
though
when a joke doesn't land does it is does
it like because like i can't i can i can
imagine it like in like a twitch
scenario i can't imagine it in a live
scenario where you're just like this
joke's gonna last like if you say a joke
on twitch right the worst thing you'll
have is someone in the chat being like
that wasn't funny yeah but when they're
in front of you
i'm sure it hurts a lot more right yeah
there's been a couple of times where
like i have a big punch line and there's
like one joke near the end of the show
that even now
like i just didn't know how to get the
punch line across right right and i
would say it and then people laughed at
the thing before it a little louder like
oh that's not the punchline like do i
move on from this now i'm like right off
there or do i but i'm
i'm a [ __ ] for a laugh i'll just
i'll keep hammering it until someone
laughs and then if it's really cringy
you just lean into that and be like
takers oh okay yeah i thought we were
here for a comedy show but i guess
and then the show in london i did it at
the troxie theater um and it i don't
know why i said that no one [ __ ]
knows what that is
but i uh yes
i i did it there and the projector broke
so the hdmi connection didn't work so
when i had to have the game on screen it
didn't show up so i had to like vamp for
a bit and like
build up the crowd and like bake it into
the show
right people said it was funny and i'm
like you got a more unique experience i
guess out of it yeah so sometimes the
cringe kind of like helps but there's
definitely times where i'm like drowning
on stage and i'm like please just now i
don't have enough material
that makes me feel good that at least i
have these two to rely on
like i don't think i could ever do like
a solo like stage show like yeah if we
drown we drown together
with enough prep you'd be able to do it
right i think i think any of you would
be able to i hope so maybe maybe two
but this time around at least it'll just
be us three we we've got each other's
backs yeah what are you guys gonna do in
the show
um
that's a really good question well i
mean like i'm start thinking about it
i mean without spoiling any of the ideas
that we have right now i like the
general idea is to bring the trash taste
experience which we're famous for just
on stage because basically what you're
experiencing right now sean we want to
we want to give the audience a little
bit of a taste of basically you know
being on the show being part of the show
kind of right you know how to paste
hopefully yeah but hopefully yeah
yeah it's tangents maybe yeah yeah see
how it goes it'll be more structured
than one of our episodes but it'll be
like you know the highlights of why you
like the trash case show and everything
just brought on stage so you have your
own running jokes that you can bring
back
till we have our own running many yeah
bring people up on stage that's always a
crowd pleaser as well and that's always
so scary though like that yeah because
it's like what if you accidentally bring
the wrong kind of purse up oh yeah that
has i'm sure that's happening it
happened in iowa where it's like i
brought people up and be like do you
have a youtube name because it's like if
you're going to sit in the chair and
like do the thing if you have a youtube
now is the time to shout it out right
yeah people here will go home and watch
you if you're good at this but then it
was a chance for people to make up their
own name and then i would make up like
titty sprinkles and things like that
right but then one guy got up and said
that he was our word giraffe
and i was like
and the crowd cheered and i was like
okay i'm like
you've got a different name
i kind of just had to like cut it off
like move on immediately but you don't
really bum the crowd out and like punish
the person on stage yeah yeah yeah
exactly but at the same time it's kind
of weird to be like all right thank you
our word gerard
it was a round of applause
for our giraffe
it was it was tough yeah oh my god
yeah i guess i guess that just comes
with experience then that like hearing
your stories that scares me but it also
makes me excited it sounds like a very
very fun experience i mean i think
everyone there
kind of because you're not like
professional comedians you're not like
john mulaney getting upset yeah yeah
people expect them to handle it better
right and like right and stuff because
i've been doing it for years and there's
like a formula to it but i think yeah
with our type of content i think people
are far more forgiving yeah if you kind
of like stall on stage and people are
like
i wouldn't know how to deal with that
yeah but like i also think like a lot of
youtubers we started off you know we
started off doing youtube videos because
we were not good at maybe like speaking
in front of like a public audience or
maybe that's just how we were as a kid
you know we never thought that we'd be
like standing up on stage in a panel
yeah and like you know public speaking
basically yeah and so it's just it's
been sometimes it's a real learning
curve to be like maybe this this is
actually really fun and it's a skill
that you develop in your career which
you never thought you would
yes
i think the secret to me for live shows
was to not be afraid of the audience
right because there's a tendency that
there's so many more of them and now
they're here and they demand a good show
because they're paying for it yeah yeah
yeah if they started heckling or
anything i would just like [ __ ] on them
immediately all right it's not a [ __ ]
classroom like you don't have all the
answers
and like bake that into the show and
then they're kind of like okay i'll be
quiet
or someone gets up and says the wrong
thing then you just hand them the mic
and be like okay good luck like you
handle the [ __ ] crowd
there's a there's a bunch of little
things like that and i think getting
over that fear of like the audience
can't like destroy me while i'm up here
yeah i should take that should have
taken notes yeah right so if only there
was some other way you could look like
yeah yeah you know i can't watch back
i don't watch my own choice
i guess like one thing i want to ask is
someone who has been doing it for this
long and who has amassed you know
the amount of subscribers yeah the cult
essentially it's like how do you see i
guess the future of like content
creation on youtube right because it's
like
you know you've obviously hit a point
that a lot of people today have not hit
you know it's it's kind of a because
like i could never relate obviously it's
like where you are right so it's like i
want to know do you reckon as someone in
your position do you see like a future
for youtube content creation because
like you were mentioning how like
recent you know culture around youtube
you're not a massive fan of not really i
don't blame it and i don't like hate
anybody who like plays into it but for
me it's not why i started
my stuff and it's it's all like idea
title and thumbnail first before
anything else anymore and then yes it is
people have like oh i have an idea how
do i do this in like fortnight because
it's like well i have to get fortnite in
there as well yeah yeah yeah people are
just playing the game and that's fine
but i i've never liked doing that yeah
always like if i find a game that's like
like a random japanese horror game that
suddenly gets four million views and
then it's like that feels better
yeah and i see that in like the trending
tab feels better than seeing all the
things you don't wanna be like a slave
to the seo base yeah kind of yeah and i
feel like i feel like my channel has
been as successful as it is like i have
the privilege of being able to do
whatever i want you played uh the
closing shift i'd played that recently
as well and that was a that was an
experience that was phenomenal what a
what a
starbucks simulator with horror in it
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i saw a lot of youtubers playing so good
yeah i didn't know what to expect and
it's just the right amount of jank to
have so much character right right oh
god yeah cause i i started going back
and playing much more of their other
games
and um
that that closing shift one is
definitely their best one like they've
started like
what they're good at basically you work
at like a starbucks at anyone doesn't
know and uh you have a stalker uh and
yeah that's kind of it okay yeah i saw a
bunch of clips it like it looks
genuinely unknown
in video game history that [ __ ] woman
with the pram yeah i [ __ ] with no
baby in it i i lost
but it's also kind of scary because you
play as a woman like at night in this
place with all these dudes like hitting
on you and it's like right this happens
yeah it's not even like a ghost showing
up it's like a [ __ ] weirdo yeah i
think it's just it's got that i i love
this game it was amazing it was so much
fun please play it if you haven't yeah
because it'll have this super
seriousness and it really builds up this
tension and then a guy will come in and
start beat like naked break dancing yeah
oh yeah i saw that clearly like it's
this game that just in the best way can
not decide what field
it wants to give you and then it like
disarms you though right because you're
scared and then this guy comes in you're
laughing and then you're like oh i
really close up and then the [ __ ] you
jump
it's so cool the other dude comes in
he's like no need to nihongo jozu
like [ __ ] off is that a natural line
yeah
honestly it's such a it's such a good
game yeah and ninety percent of it is
you making coffees
right it's so stressful definitely gonna
try that out it's so good i think
especially as like a you know as a
content creator there's definitely that
aspect of like this stalking thing is a
little too yeah yeah
it's just made by two japanese brothers
yeah they're just gonna buy chill as an
art on yeah
but they make really really good games
because their old stuff is all like
supernatural [ __ ] yeah i feel like
they're really getting into like real
stuff yeah yeah and it's so much scarier
yeah
now that you're like you've
your content is so like obviously like
revolved around gaming before has that
changed your relationship with gaming at
all no i game all the [ __ ] time yeah
right are you a gamer
are you a gamer and i have a girlfriend
impossible
he's also touch grass
i am i mean i still i pick and choose
what i play more
i think this time right still sometimes
i'm like a game comes out i'm like [ __ ]
i should have played that on my channel
it was so good right right right it's
like very hit and miss sometimes and
then
i don't know i just i like having games
for myself i think that's my favorite
pastime yeah and i like how they're made
and i i always kind of wanted to get
into game design and voice work and
stuff so
i think from a mechanical standpoint
i still really like them quite a bit and
artistically and
they're just so good and they just keep
getting better well there's so many
people that's like your recent favorite
game elden ring yeah
yeah that's exactly why i haven't
started yet because you love me berserk
and haven't played have you played this
you can play yes i have yeah okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah i play bloodborne like
the dark souls games like i love from
but like i know i'll get into it and
that's exactly why i'm scared to get
into it it's like final fantasy 14. like
i know i'll get into it but i know if i
start right commitments out the window
it's worth it it definitely ruined my
life right it's worth it it's like
amazing yeah no it is like if it had
come out like
this time last year you know like in the
middle of the pandemic it was supposed
to come out earlier okay no need to rub
it yeah right we waited so long exactly
it was the perfect pandemic game and now
i'm like traveling in like [ __ ] four
different countries in like three months
or whatever i'm like this is it'll be
there yeah it is definitely a daunting
task to take on because the first place
was like 70 hours yeah yeah because
meanwhile there's a guy who can beat in
like three minutes
as well he's not even playing eldon
right yeah yeah he's playing dance dance
revolution and [ __ ] is happening on the
screen he's like coding the game yeah
the zipping of speed runs are like
what the [ __ ] is the point of this i
mean he doesn't even like them on his
streams he's like i [ __ ] i wish i
could fight things
i wish i could play the game yeah yeah
his bloodborne one is still really
really good and that's all like
perfecting like the craft yeah yeah i
think the bosses yeah
yeah
i guess i guess like final question like
is that you've done already so much of
your career is that is there anything
you want to do in the future
like you know you've done multiple tours
now you've amassed a massive following
you've met ryan reynolds like i don't
think there's
anything else where does it go from ryan
reynolds
i
yeah i think i think narrative stuff is
kind of where i'm headed right i kind of
had like projects in the back of my head
and stuff that i've wanted to do for a
long time like stories and right like
acting out characters and stuff and i
think i'll probably get into that right
hell no
there's a big pressure to write books
years ago when everyone was doing them
now yeah i haven't lived a life
like what am i going to write i think
you have now yeah
the jack cook book
you can write a whole chapter watch out
on being friends with right
yeah i don't know i just kind of want to
focus on the coffee stuff and i feel
like i haven't even like nearly started
cranking that as much as i could right
right just kind of before i was like
taking on too many things and doing them
all kind of poorly right right right a
few things and do them a bit better and
yeah
yeah yeah yeah sounds like mine yeah
sounds like a good path well i guess
well thank you for coming on the show no
problem thank you for having me thank
you so much patrons though oh my god you
see all of them john look at them all
yeah
why are they here
because i support the show people pay
for this
is that crazy
that name there
this is just a shame credit
but hey if you'd like to join the shane
crowds go over to our patreon
patreon.com also follow us on twitter
send us some memes on the subreddit and
if you hate our face listen to us on
spotify and uh yeah i mean you already
know who [ __ ] do you want a shout out
you know who it is you want to shout out
your socials jack find my coffee oh yeah
there you go oh yeah yeah my socials
mean nothing what is the top of the
morning coffee.com there you go there
you go did i get that right yeah uh hell
yeah your sponsors for this episode are
going to be very upset
that's my inspiration
another one
yeah thanks for coming on man thank you
very much thank you very much and we'll
see you guys uh in the next episode as
well
bye stay weeby
[Music]
you